Oh.
It's time.
You've all waited 50 years for this moment.
Boy, it's not over the doors like a sliding thing.
Oh!
You guys deal with a death counter.
You guys count in your head.
I don't want to put my shame.
Oh, fuck it.
I'll put my shame out here.
Alright.
Let me get the death counter.
Let me get that in.
Oh, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Let's go!
Zyko, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Let's freakin go.
It's been 84 years.
This is it.
This is what we've been waiting for.
Finally, she's doing the thing.
Oh my God.
Guys, I need to like remember word.
Okay.
What is it?
App for counting twi- Guys, I don't remember what I used for number counting twi- Guys, I don't remember what I used for number counting twi- Give me a sec.
I knew I had something for it, but I don't remember where it is.
It's been so long.
It's actually been so fucking long.
Okay, tally counting.
All right.
Tally counting.
Okay, count up and- Okay, it's a- Oh, it's an OBS.
Okay, well, does anyone have- Does anyone have a program that can use to get a tally thing?
Does anyone have one?
Um- Johnny, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
We awaited this day.
Now the prophecy shall be complete.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
NS, thank you for the Super Chat.
Welcome to die.
Um...
Aphelion.
Krish, thank you for the 10 gifted ships and 5 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Zekra, thank you for the Akka Supa.
The Toki Ring is finally happening.
Ah, I don't wanna tap out and tap in every time I die.
That's more shame.
I have to pause and then like register that I fucking died.
And then we do it all over again.
We are not tapping in and out.
We are not doing that.
I wanna just press a button and then it registers.
And then I just go straight in and never change my strategy.
And just keep brute forcing it until something dies.
Like...
There's a reason why we haven't played Souls games.
And so fucking lie.
You know when was the last time we played Souls games?
Fucking Bloodborne.
You have to bribe me to fucking keep playing Souls games.
Just like a real gamer.
You have to fucking bribe me to do this.
Okay.
Um, there's a mod.
Elden Ring mod.
Oh my god.
Now I can look at my death counter.
Okay.
This is a mod.
Alright.
Okay.
Where's this mod that you speak of?
I know I could have researched.
I didn't research anything about Elden Ring.
The only...
I told you guys.
My only experience in Elden Ring was helping my dad.
I don't remember why.
It was like kill a boss.
Because he...
He was like fucking 60 levels above what he should be.
He was 60 plus levels above what he should fucking be.
And couldn't even kill the first story boss.
So he gave me the controller and killed the first story boss.
Um...
Because he did some fucking...
Unlimited...
He did some...
What was it?
Some glitch where you fight these people on the cliffs.
Over and over and over and over again.
To get like more and more souls.
And then he still couldn't beat the...
And he was a fucking magic user too.
Like he...
He was a...
He was a fucking...
I would...
I remember just waking up.
Seeing my dad on the PlayStation 5.
And he still be on the cliff.
Still farming those things.
I don't remember what they were.
And then like...
He still...
I was like...
Oh, did you fight your first boss yet?
And he's like...
No, I keep dying.
And I was like...
How?
You're like...
I'm pretty sure he was 60 plus levels above what he should be.
On the first boss.
So I was like...
How?
And then I...
I don't remember if I first tried or second tried the boss.
Because I do one hit.
And then the boss was like...
Lost like...
30% of his HP.
I...
I was like...
How?
I was...
I don't know.
Do we...
Maybe he's just old.
That's gonna be you.
That's gonna be you when you're at a dad age.
That's right.
You're gonna be like, I'm a gamer.
And then you have to give your controller to your fucking kid.
To help you beat bosses.
That's gonna be you one day.
That's not...
No!
Yeah.
You're gonna be like, I don't know how I can kill this boss.
It's just...
And then you have to give your controller to your child.
And your child's gonna first try it.
That's gonna be you.
That's the day I quit.
No.
Don't say that.
Don't...
Yeah.
Seats many tarnished.
Walk among the dragoons.
Bound by grace.
And united by the love for Elden Ring.
Thank you to Akasupa.
Thank you.
Nature.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Thank you.
Armina.
Thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
Try bleed for an easy time.
I heard bleed was good.
I don't know what any of that means.
But...
You guys just see my chat and be like, Oh, I hope she goes for bleed build.
Or like, I hope she does this build.
I...
I have no idea what those words mean.
But like...
Cool.
Um...
Okay.
Alright.
So...
Is it a Nexus mod?
The death counter shit?
Or like...
Can I...
Okay.
I don't know.
Alright.
This mod has been set...
Def...
Okay.
This...
Please use this...
Def counter for OBS.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Def counter.
Is a tool that automatically counts the number of deaths in Elden Ring.
Works with anti...
It can be used with OBS.
No need to use the script.
It will automatically load the deaths that are there before it was installed.
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
Alright.
Let me download this real quick.
That's an ad.
Okay.
Where's the fucking download button?
Oh my god.
You...
Okay.
Manual?
What?
There's no automatic download?
Oh my god.
Guys.
We're all doing this live.
Alright.
I have to do a manual download apparently.
You must be logged.
Oh my god.
Do I have an...
I do.
I do have an account guys.
We're all doing this live so it's authentic.
Uh...
FateSmile.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Um...
Kids being bosses.
Bold of you to assume any of us will ever be anything but Maiden West.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Oh, they have to reactivate my account.
You sure you don't know what's important before it's gone.
Either way.
I love you and the dragoons.
LG.
You got this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm downloading it.
Guys.
I'm downloading it so we can have our death...
We can have our stupid fucking death counter.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
I already forgot how to install this.
Alright.
What it says.
Know you to use this...
Okay.
Install this.
Run.
Okay.
Next.
Install.
Finished.
Select your game if you're using global mod that's own chain.
Select that you don't need to create that one.
Just select the folder when you want.
Necessary.
Change the format.
You have multiple characters.
Select the profile index you want to use.
What?
Oh.
I have to create the text.
Okay.
Guys.
I figured it out.
The fuck?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Guys.
I figured it out.
Alright.
I need to find the app data.
We're doing it live.
You're learning.
Okay.
Now.
By doing this live.
You guys are going to learn with me.
So if you want to do it too.
Then.
Like you know.
We all learning it.
We're all learning it together.
So now you know how to do it.
For your own playthrough.
So like.
You know.
I'm basically educating people.
I'm Woah.
Okay.
App data.
Elden Ring.
Where the fuck is my app data?
Okay, where did I install Elden Ring?
Okay, app... Where the fuck is my app data?
Where... Okay, guys, where does app data usually go to?
Where does app data usually exist in?
Where does it exist?
Guys, we're learning together!
Where?
Okay, app data.
I'll search this up.
Wait, why didn't it take me to app data?
Where the fuck is it?
Okay.
Go to control plus... Oh.
Oh, okay.
I got this, guys.
Control.
All right, guys, we're learning together.
Guys, I know there are people out there who are like, what the fuck is app data?
Like, I can't be the only one that's stupid.
I found app data!
You know how I did it?
I didn't read chat.
I...
I looked at control R app data.
Now, where is Elden Ring?
Where the fuck...
Is it because I never...
Oh, is it because I haven't ran Elden Ring yet that it doesn't exist yet?
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna run at Elden Ring for the first time.
I'm...
This is the final boss.
All right.
Skellum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If she's having this much trouble, imagine her trying to stream the Dead Space remake.
Hey, look.
It worked in the end.
It worked in...
I'd do anything for my frames.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
First time running Elden Ring.
Okay, let me...
All right.
Also, how's the mic?
We did some little...
Um, we adjusted the mic settings after the last...
After stream yesterday.
So, I hope that I sound a little bit better.
I hope...
Okay, thank God.
I was like, I hope I'm not lagging.
So, we adjusted it a little bit.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to show my game on...
God damn it.
Okay, there it is.
All right.
You got this.
I don't know if I should play with mouse and keyboard or controller.
Because I feel like reaction-wise, I might react better with mouse and keyboard.
But then rage-wise, I think my viewers will hate me more if I use mouse and keyboard.
I...
I think I would rage bait people more if I use M and K.
Do not use M and K.
Okay.
Uh...
Enrage the drag goons.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Now.
New game.
Wait.
Let me see.
System.
All right.
Auto target.
Okay.
Super to enrage the rest of chat.
Use mouse and keyboard.
I think you made a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm just wondering.
I know rage bait wise.
I know more people will be mad if I use M and K.
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Use M and K just to spite them.
All right.
Let's see.
Um...
Wow.
I wonder what those controls are in mouse and keyboard.
I wonder what they are.
Wow.
That's a lot.
A lot of controls.
Um...
Def counter.
Mouse and key.
All right.
Let's see.
Advanced settings.
Ooh.
Hi.
But I just want motion blur, please.
Motion blur off.
All right.
That should be good.
Let me see.
I'm just checking if...
Yeah.
I'm bouncing.
All right.
Okay.
Back.
All right.
Uh...
But set the on-screen prompts and settings on controller.
So no one will know.
Wait.
I can do that?
I'll be confused.
No.
I can't.
I'll be confused if we do that.
Like, that's gonna fuck me up.
I...
He's a dance dance revolution dance bat.
Right?
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, how would that help me?
Hehehehe.
Okay.
Um...
Music down by one and game...
Game volume up.
Okay.
Let's see.
We'll do music volume down by one and then game volume up.
Okay.
Let me know if that's better.
I up the game volume a little bit.
Okay.
Let me just close all these other things.
Let me find...
Did Elder Ring show up yet?
Oh, it did.
Okay.
Elder Ring showed up, guys.
Where the fuck is the...
Save file?
Where...
Where is it?
Do I have to install it again?
Because I didn't boot up...
Maybe I have to install it again because I didn't boot it up.
Oh, no.
I don't.
Oh, select save file.
I don't have a save file.
I don't have one.
I don't...
What do you want from me?
I don't have one.
Okay.
There we go.
And then... Okay, I guess I'll show up afterwards?
Question mark?
Alright, let's see.
Sorry, guys.
I'm just trying to figure this out.
There's a... Oh, there it is!
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, we did it.
Defs.
Zero.
What if I just kept it at zero?
This entire run.
So new people would be, like, so impressed, guys.
They'd be like, wow, I can't believe Doki.
I can't believe Doki never died once.
Wait, my mic peeked first?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I got a little closer to my mic.
I'm sorry, guys.
What if it just never moved?
Alright.
Okay, new game.
Uh, adjust brightness until the image on the right.
I mean, that works.
Camera speed.
Okay.
Alright.
What do I want to be?
What are these?
Show attributes?
Okay, let's see.
Level 9.
Oh, I want to be higher level.
Level.
Oh, I guess this is, like, hard, right?
Oh, I guess this is easy, medium, hard.
Because, like, they're level 7.
No, we are not doing the fucking...
Oh, no, these are classes.
Never mind.
I just realized there's...
There's more.
Okay.
I just realized...
I was like, oh, I get it.
She didn't get it.
I didn't see the arrows.
Alright.
Confessor.
Prisoner.
Samurai.
Oh, that's cool.
For...
Uh...
Prophet.
Astrologer.
Bandit.
Why would you ever want to be a fucking bandit?
Uh...
Let's see it.
Why are you still on M&K?
That's why.
That's...
Has the best starting weapon?
Okay.
I'll go with Samurai, then.
Wait.
Where's the pro player?
Come on.
Where's the guy that makes guides?
If I'm listening to anyone...
I'm listening to the guy who's literally making YouTube videos about Souls games.
I...
Wait.
I swear, if you lie to me...
I swear to fucking God.
I...
Dude.
I swear, if you lie to me and feed me false information...
I will know.
Oh.
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For the real 4D chest move.
Use DK bongos instead.
Also, probably have to watch this.
So, enjoy it, goons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Do we do Samurai?
Or, like...
I don't know.
What else to do?
Everything.
Okay.
But, what is Doki playable?
Oh.
But, anything is usable.
Alright.
That's all I need.
I mean, I was looking at Samurai in the first place, too.
I was like, ooh, Samurai.
I look pretty cool.
I guess, like...
I'll make a dragon.
Alright.
Dragon.
All right.
Zero.
Death.
It's so true.
If I write it down, it's true.
Alright.
There we go.
Age.
Old.
Origin.
Keepsake.
What's Keepsake?
No.
The past has been...
Oh!
More buffs!
Alright.
Increases maximum HP.
The people used to gain many runes.
Said to enhance Sacred Flask.
The fuck does any of this mean?
The Ashes are small, diminutive golems.
Ashes are said to hold spirits within.
The Golden Seed?
Oh!
Does it mean more heals?
I believe that's more heals, right?
Oh, fuck god.
It's fine.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
We'll go with a template.
And then we'll, like, go from there.
We'll...
We'll go from there.
Alright.
We'll do a template.
And then we'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
Okay.
Detailed.
Wait, how do I hear the voice?
Okay.
I like this one.
Alright.
Where's...
Where's purple?
Where's Urpa?
Yellow.
Sorry.
Where's yellow?
Sorry!
It was reflex from our last Souls games.
The last time we did a Souls games, it was just reflex from that.
When we made the last dragon.
Not your ancestors.
There we go.
That's hot.
Whoops.
How do I keep this?
Okay.
How do I accept?
E.
Okay.
There we go.
Yellow.
Alright.
Adjust face.
I remember you can make...
You can actually make, like, Bob Ross.
Uh...
Richard.
Alright.
Adjust face template.
I know.
I like the face for this.
So far.
Oh my god.
This is...
Okay.
Ian.
7D?
Like...
Why would this have a bigger nose?
Okay.
There you go.
Facial aesthetic.
The...
Oh, it's just...
Yes.
Um...
It's like a beak.
You know?
Yes.
Okay.
Back.
Hair.
Okay.
I should have liked that...
That crazy hair you guys had.
Uh...
Why do we have to...
Because you're a yellow!
You're a bird!
I actually like the...
Where...
What's the crazy hair I got?
Oh my god.
I could just make Rick Sanchez.
From Rick and Morty.
You know what?
Wait.
What was the other hair that...
What is the default hair?
Okay.
Default hair is that.
I like this.
And then...
We'll get...
Wait.
What was the color that they gave us?
This?
Okay.
We'll make white.
So it's like the...
It's like the horns.
You know?
It's like...
And it's like Rick Sanchez.
I really like your Simpsons.
See?
Okay.
What is this?
Oh, luster.
Okay.
We'll have it here.
And then...
Root darkness.
Okay.
We got a little shading in here.
I mean...
You already have white hair.
So it doesn't matter.
Um...
I think I'm...
Wait.
Skin features?
Pores?
Dark circles?
Yes.
Yes, from watching...
From watching me.
No.
Yes.
From watching me.
That makes sense.
What is this?
Uh...
No, you guys don't need scars.
Back.
Cosmetic.
Eyes.
I think eyes are fine.
Ooh.
Eyelashes.
Nice.
You're beautiful.
But I want it to be a little darker.
It's gonna be eyelashes.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Body time.
Smaller head means...
Less headshots.
The smaller your head, the less we'll get headshot.
Guys.
That's how it goes.
We're just reducing our hitbox.
We're...
We're reducing our hitbox, guys!
Guys!
Uh...
We'll keep that.
That's abdomen.
Oh...
I like current...
Oh, my arms.
Okay.
We focus on legs here.
The game.
Okay.
And then...
Nice.
Muscular?
No.
Beautiful.
Alright.
I think I'm okay now.
There you go.
Exactly.
I saved lives.
The Koomba.
Thank you for the super chat.
Not the Deadpool.
Thank you.
Okay.
How do I agree to my character?
There you go.
I did it.
What do I do now?
What do I...
I... I like this.
This is how... I want to be this.
What do I do?
I want to be this.
How do I... Oh, back out?
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
It's okay.
It's not like you can see any...
I'm just gonna be wearing clothes anyway.
But we'll know on the inside what he looks like.
I was gonna say, like, it doesn't matter what we make.
Because in the end, everything's gonna be covered up.
But we know in the inside.
What you look like.
We know.
Noo.
Yeah.
We know.
You're Rick Sanchez.
Yes.
Well, noo.
We know what you are.
On the inside, we're so beautiful.
Oh?
Hello?
Oh, the game is super low?
Sorry, let me fix that.
Let me know if it's better.
I can turn it up more.
Oh!
Sorry.
Oh, I know him!
He's the guy that turned around.
He turns into a big-ass dragon!
I know him!
That's the girl that everybody wants to bang!
With the multiple arms!
So low?
Okay, I'll up the voice more.
See?
I'm not going in completely blind!
Wife!
And I'm one of the... What,
is that Melania?
The bitch?
A war leading to abandonment.
Yes.
Like how you don't even, like, correct me.
You're just like, yes, that's her.
Oh!
Rise now, ye tarnished, ye dead, who yet live.
The call of long-lost grace speaks to us all.
Horaloo, chieftain of the Badlands.
The ever-brilliant gold mask.
Fear!
Oh, she's cute.
The dead dead companion.
Of her dead husband, I assume.
The lope's a dung eater.
What?
Bro, that's sad.
Your name is the lope's a dung eater?
Oh my god, that's so sad.
We all know him.
Imagine being named a dung eater.
That's your legacy.
And then right after, it's the all-knowing.
Like...
The- Why do the other guys have such good names?
And then he's the fucking shit eater.
He des- He deserves it.
You eat dung one time, and then everybody calls you the dung eater.
He knows what he did.
The Losa Marvel Rivals player.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
I'm gonna become the Elden Lord!
Let's go!
Alright.
Okay, let's me look at how to attack.
Oh, I assume that's the arrow.
Oh, that is.
Okay.
Set- Oh wait, no.
That's not what I wanted.
Um...
Where's my s- I saw- I saw S and I assumed I went straight to like sat- settings.
Uh...
I need my sensitivity to be lower.
I don't like it.
God, why is it Q for back?
It's so fucking weird.
I don't like that.
Yeah, I'll do three.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Though the path be broken and uncertain, claim your place as Elden Lord.
Okay.
I can do that.
Joy ahead.
Yay!
Open only those- Wait, what?
Only- open only to those carrying a finger.
Oh.
Who has a finger?
Oh, this guy.
Okay.
Yay!
Hey, hey, hey.
Wait, how did you die?
What did you do?
Fucking stupid.
I said that I would do that.
Wait, how did he die?
Wait a minute.
I thought that was a cliff.
How did you die?
Why?
Oh, I'm fucking- I was like, wait a minute.
Okay.
Alright, look.
I-
Okay, that was pretty troll.
That is pretty troll.
Must be like, items here.
Why else would there be an empty area?
Any items?
Wait.
Why am I using my- Oh shit.
Why am I using my arrows?
Why- How do I change?
It's tradition.
Oh no.
How do I change my weapon?
Where's my HUD?
I should have a HUD?
I have no idea.
Oh, HUD to always on.
Good idea.
I was like, I should have a HUD?
I was confused.
Alright, let's see.
HUD?
Oh, it's on auto.
On.
Okay.
There we go.
How do I- How can my sword up?
How does that work?
Wait, what's this?
Checkpoint ahead?
The door is blocked shut.
Okay, I can't do that.
Probably arrow keys?
No.
No way.
That's bad.
That's- That's bad.
That's- That's really bad.
We got- I'm rebinding that right now.
It cannot be arrow key.
Let me- Let me rebind that.
Right now.
Control scroll up?
Bro, no one has time for that.
No one.
What do you mean I can't- Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That works.
Okay.
There we go.
I got it.
We go.
We go straight down.
First off, tarnish.
Behold.
Lift ahead.
I don't know if I trust him.
I don't- I don't know.
He's pointing out there.
He's- Hmm.
Seems off.
First off, and then praise the message.
Poor!
That's a bad message.
Alright.
Never trust.
E for two hand?
There's no two hand.
Down- Look, if you ask me to upvote you, I downvote.
E left click.
Okay.
Oh.
E left click.
Alright.
If only I had a rump.
Strange strong foe ahead.
Rushing in ahead.
Oh!
This is just- You don't have to fight him.
Be wary of strong foe.
See, therefore, revenge.
Okay, I know like, for this, you die regardless.
Because...
My dad tried to redo this multiple times.
And like, gave up.
I know that you are supposed to die.
But like, obviously you can kill him if you're good.
But we know this is gonna be...
Death counter plus one.
We- If you're- And you think I am good?!
Didn't expect weak foe.
Why is it always- Okay, goodbye.
And I have zero heals, guys.
I have zero heals.
Like, I-
That was fast.
There we go.
I was like, wait.
I don't have heals.
Alright.
Look!
I got a dodge.
I dodged.
One time.
Fair.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Viewers choose.
Mouse and keyboard.
Instantly regretted.
I didn't die.
Look, my death counter says zero.
I technically did not die.
Oh, I got my little horsey.
Or my goat.
Talk to- Talk to get to play for you.
Oh, George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fortune is on his side.
Wait, so how many wives do I have?
Found him here, after all.
No, no, no, Varson.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you not see- Let me- Let me tap the monitor.
It says zero.
One of his kind is sure to seek.
The Elden Ring.
Even
if it does violate the-
No, no, no.
Let me tap the screen.
Zero.
You can't say you are Maidenless.
I'm literally playing as you guys.
So you're flaming yourselves.
And what you say about this character is yourself.
I know what I am.
Oh, nice.
Now I have healers.
Nice.
Blask of Tears?
Cool.
I don't know what that is.
The Cave of Knowledge lies.
Jump down and you'll find- There you can learn more about the game's control.
As well as other tips that will be helpful- Oh wait, I need to do that.
Ready, Tarnish, take the plunge of learning and remembrance.
Recall the arts of war and your warrior's blood.
Okay.
Yay!
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Use.
Okay, and then...
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta fix that.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
There we go.
That's a lot better.
Okay.
Alright, we're just figuring this out.
Alright.
Enemy ahead.
Where?
Resting will destroy your HP, FP, and cleanse any- Oh, this is the bonfire.
Okay.
Noah!
I can do this.
Alright.
Where's the enemy?
Be wary of weak foe.
Oh, he's here?
Hello?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
He's so weak.
That was so easy.
We have strong attacks?
What does a strong attack do?
Use an on your left hand to guard- Guardings for pussies.
Guardings for pussy!
Oh, wait.
Dodge, roll, and then shift.
That's fucking right.
True.
So true.
Why dodge when I can roll?
Why- Well spoken.
Look carefully.
Time for sniper?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, I can just run past him.
Alright.
Exactly.
Why- Why guard when I can just roll?
Each hand can be equipped.
Switch to right.
Wield with two hands.
Can also be making attacks more difficult to repel with shield and boosting- Ooh!
Nice.
I like that.
What you gonna do, huh?
That's fucking- NOTHING!
That's right!
What?
Oh, I need to learn how to lock on.
Wait, I can do jump attack?
Ooh, I can.
Alright, he's not gonna expect it.
I'm so fast.
Oh!
That's right.
Can't do jack shit.
I'm invincible.
I'm so strong.
Equip the bow to fight.
You can equip two types.
Rage is also for pussies!
Look at that!
Oh shit!
I'm so- I forgot to lock on!
Okay.
Alright, all I'm saying is- All I'm saying is that he- He did swap the sword.
He did swap the sword.
I- That's all I'm saying.
That's all I'm saying.
Skills are- Using skills consumes FP?
I- Use it?
I don't know if I used it.
Is that- Is that my skill?
Is that it?
There.
My first death.
What does it consume?
Oh!
It consumes my magic!
I was like, the fuck did it consume?
Crouching can make it harder.
Especially attacking as knowing it will cause more damage than usual.
Crouch.
Oh, there it is.
Hello, little guy.
Surprise attack!
Alright.
Look, I was gonna say something similar to that, but I was like, Is that appropriate?
No, Doki, that's not appropriate.
I- Rube, like, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I- I contemplated it.
Good!
See?
That's a good appraisal right there.
That's- Oh!
I could've done this!
Oh my god!
That would've been even better!
I'm sad.
Near a critical hit if his back is turned.
Oh!
That's good.
There we go.
That's the critical hit.
Yeah, but it told me to just left click it.
So I listened.
Yeah, I wanna try this skill.
Sometimes may break giving you a chance to perform a critical hit.
Hold control, charge, control while jumping.
Oh, okay.
Try.
Is that the critical hit?
Oh shit!
Wait, that looks so cool!
I'm gonna forget how to do that.
We revived at the last sight of grace that you visited.
However, if there is a state near where you died, you can choose to revive there instead.
Oh, this?
Why can we revive there?
That's not a crit?
That's just a posture break?
Oh!
Oh, I have to be closer for it.
But I still looked so cool though!
I looked so cool!
Oh, is this a boss fight?
Oh.
Wait, but this is a tutorial.
That's r- Oh.
After blocking...
Blocking me.
I don't need a block!
Oh shit!
Sorry!
Wait!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh god!
Okay, let me recharge that.
Let me...
Let me recharge...
I still don't need a block!
That's right!
I told you!
I don't need a block!
If I never learn how to parry, I'll never learn how to block.
I didn't...
First try!
I told you!
She...
What?
That's right!
Not a blood stain here!
Look at all these pussies!
Look at all these people that died on the first tutorial box!
Let's go!
All these people died in the tutorial box!
Not me!
Where do I go?
Where did I came from?
I got lost.
Wait...
Oh shit!
There's two entrances!
There's...
She beat Soulja, got rigged the very first attempt!
Could she...
Okay, this is where I came from!
I got a little sidetrack there!
Wait...
Oh wait!
That's just nothing!
Oh, that's...
These are just like...
When I looked in...
Fortnite...
Hole...
Yes...
Wait, how do I make my own?
I wanna make my own!
I wanna make my own little thingy...
Do this...
Classic...
In menu?
Oh, messages...
Okay...
Oh my god, okay...
Messages...
Template...
Still...
Uh...
Let's see...
I wanna say...
What under...
Oh my god...
Okay, is there...
Die...
Situations...
Places...
Affinities...
Concept...
Death...
Wait, I want more!
Can I not have more...
What the fuck is this?
Okay...
Death?
Death...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
That's it...
Death?
Ha ha ha ha...
That's it...
There you go...
We're gonna like this...
That's good enough.
That shows people that I'm a gamer.
Didn't expect but I failed.
Why did you fail this?
Did you drop?
Why did you die?
Oh.
Oh, okay, that makes sense.
Oh, nice.
Strength.
Got strength.
Okay.
I hope me jumping down from here means I don't die.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
We're good.
Poor gravity.
He got gravitated.
He died in the tutorial hole.
When there's a hole, there's a goal.
Who could blame him?
The hole was right there.
Alright.
Touch.
Yay!
Okay, I need a heal.
Pass time.
Flask.
What's this?
Add charge to flask?
Allocate flask charges?
Oh!
Okay.
Do I add right now?
Oh, that's my gold.
Oh!
Can I just add it now?
Use it?
Okay.
Alright.
Can I just keep adding it?
Oh.
Can I just keep doing it?
Oh, I only add one?
God damn it.
Alright.
What's this?
Use sacred tear to increase the amount?
Do I have one?
I don't even know if I have one.
Okay, I'll put it all in healers.
Yes.
Alright.
Uh... Leave.
Alright, I should be good now.
Wait, why is this?
Why is there smokey air?
Let me in!
Oh my goodness.
Suffering ahead?
Why?
Who's suffering?
Use Tarnished World to write a golden summon.
Cooperative members will begin once you have been summoned by a player.
You'll take the role of an ally and your objective is defeat the area boss.
Oh.
Okay.
Tarnished World finger.
Oh, so there is the co-op.
Very happy you finally played this game.
Reminder that you owe us 11 story bosses.
Oh!
No, no, no!
You can't gaslight me.
It was five.
That was neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You think I don't remember, do you?
I knew it was five.
Secret passage ahead?
Where's the passage?
Is he lying?
Secret passage.
Where's the other appraisal?
Alright.
No, it's true.
I just keep hitting it?
Let me in!
It said there's secret passages!
Oh my god!
I...
Bad message!
Poor!
Oh, you guys paid 5-11?
Oh my god, okay.
I don't know you're gaslighting me.
I...
I don't know!
I don't...
No.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Then try...
I'm not praising that message.
Poor!
There we go.
You gotta be...
How dare you.
I will fucking pour every message that lies to me.
Be wary of enemy?
Who's the enemy?
Oh?
Yeah!
Yes!
My message got a praise!
Wait!
Somebody found my message!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Someone liked my tweet, guys!
I'm...
Oh my god, I'm famous!
I'm fucking famous, guys!
My tweet got liked!
Okay.
Lost Grace Discovery.
Exist to guide the tarnish and lead them along.
Even now, some sites like Grace, their golden rays will guide you along the way.
Use your map to check your, as well as Terran and surrounding structures.
You can update your map with new information by finding map fragments.
And use the map.
Okay.
Hello!
Where did he die?
Oh my god, next to the pretty...
...lady?
Idiot!
Oh, mad!
Tarnished, are we?
Come to the lands between for the Elden Ring?
Hmm?
Of course you have.
No shame in it.
Unfortunately for you, however, you are maidenless.
Without guidance, without the strength of runes, and without an invitation...
What?
But there's so many maidens!
It seems to die in obscurity.
No!
I can't die maidenless!
They can't do this to me!
Oh no, my job here is to get a maiden.
Before it's too late.
Okay, what's over here?
I don't know if there's anything here.
Ooh!
Can I kill those birds over there?
Hello, little birds!
I'm gonna let my anger out on you because I'm maidenless.
Nice!
Oh!
Nice, I gotta...
That's right, if I'm gonna be maidenless...
...I shall kill all birds.
Get over here.
That's right, I'm angry.
Oh, hey, there's bones!
I got some bones, though!
Murder time!
Why?
What's the point?
You told me I have no women in my life.
What's the point anymore?
No, Duke, you have so much to live for!
You don't need maidens!
That's what people who have no maidens would say!
Oh my god, I can't believe I missed.
Might as well jump because of that.
Alright.
Don't do it!
Do a flip!
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
There's a...
There's a thing here.
You may find effigies of martyrs.
These are summoning pools.
You'll find easy summons at these as co-ops and hostile summoning sites.
Created with small effigies scattered at summoning pools.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The summoning pool is now functional.
What did I do?
What is that?
I mean, I know what it is, but...
Try friend.
Oh!
Did someone come over?
There's no one come- I am not fighting that!
I know I lose!
I might not have done my research, but...
Elder Ring fans, you don't need it...
You don't have to look far for Elder Ring fans to spam your timeline about this guy.
I am...
This tradition...
Not for me!
I shall bring tradition!
I...
Can't get me if I'm crouched!
I am...
I think it's particularly hot that I have zero deaths right now.
Uh... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys are saying cowards because you all died to him too.
So you want me to join.
You just... you just want me to be just like you.
Dying first try at this guy.
I know you never beat him.
Until, like, when you're 30 plus levels.
He's not even an actual boss!
No head ahead.
Oh, hey, I'm at a church now.
Let's go.
It's a right one of us.
One of us.
I miss the travel to any sites of grace that you discovered.
How there's some dungeons and other areas where this cannot be done.
Zero deaths equals zero made.
No food, thank you but...
But I'm alive!
Yes, there's a guy that died to him!
Yay!
My message got outvoted.
You know what?
Fuck you guys.
Let me... make a message.
Um...
Let's see.
All right.
What do I want?
Let's see.
Victory.
Oh, he's here to...
I can buy stuff from him.
Wait, what's wrong with his donkey?
Purchase about Kale.
He's gonna give it up for her rating.
He has been tainted by madness since the shattering of...
He's Santa?
It's only tarnished, like yourself.
Who keep things from drying up entirely.
Let's say you're a very welcome customer.
What?
What's his recommendation?
If you can spare the rooms, you should buy yourself a crafting kit.
Oh?
The crafting kit allows you to make...
Yay!
Message was liked.
Essential, really.
If you intend to survive out here for any duration.
The kit costs a bundle.
And I admit, I do take my cut.
But the important thing is that you survive.
Every customer counts.
After all.
Okay.
Can I afford it?
You can spend runes to purchase various...
You can also sell items for runes.
Is there anything I should buy?
Right now?
Cracked pot.
Crafting?
This one?
Crafting, cracked pot items.
Reveals co-op and hostile summoning signs.
Top right.
Oh, crafting kit.
There it is.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
How do I use this crafting kit though?
I'm glad you took my warning to heart.
You've made an excellent choice.
Yeah.
You can make various items for materials I find.
Item crafting from...
You can learn to craft by finding...
Cookbooks.
Oh!
I can start cooking!
Cannot be able to make more than you have.
Items will run with...
Outward use.
But canary cells will remain.
Oh, okay.
Item crafting.
What can I make?
You can learn to craft by...
More items by finding...
Oh!
Okay.
So currently I can find...
Craft...
Feed to...
Torrent to restore HP.
Who the fuck is Torrent?
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
All right.
I'm back.
Uh, Solid.
Hey, Affiliant.
Laffy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Devil, thank you for the super chat.
Hot tip.
Messages on the ground.
You place heal you.
So chat can be your...
Wait.
Is that true?
That's an actual strat?
Wait.
That's fucking broken.
That's actually so broken.
Uh...
Subaru, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Wait.
That's actually...
Really?
Oh my god.
I should just leave messages everywhere.
What if I'm like...
At a boss fight...
And I just leave like...
10 messages...
At the boss...
I just leave...
I just leave like...
10 messages...
At the boss area.
And SMC's like...
Yeah.
Bro, that's pain...
That's stream to win.
Okay.
Wait.
That's actually...
That's stream to win.
Alright.
Let's see.
Um...
I want to see I can find...
Is there like...
I can find something.
Incantation...
Flask...
I need like...
Where's the flask one?
Is there...
Is there like...
Is there a flask?
Okay.
Word?
No.
Stop that.
It's not cheating.
I'm just trying to warn people.
Guys.
I...
Is there...
I need healing.
Where's...
I need...
I need healing.
Do it.
Alright.
I...
I want to go home.
Same.
Wait.
Actions has healing.
Surcery summoning.
Healing.
Alright guys.
Stand near this one.
Just stand near this one.
If you want to heal me.
Just stand here.
And keep up voting.
Just give me up dudes here.
This is my reddit post.
Um...
You can spend runes and smithing stones to train your armaments.
Somewhere in the lands between you and me.
A blacksmith who can make your armaments even stronger.
Um...
Oh, okay.
Let me fix that.
Oh.
Voice.
Voice up by...
Up to ten.
Music.
Down by one.
And then overall volume up.
Alright.
I got you.
Let me know this is better.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I keep accidentally tabbing out.
And I feel like my game is going to crash.
I...
Where do I go?
Oh, here.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh no.
You can check the current terrain buildings.
You can also freely place beacons of light to serve as landmarks.
Lastly though, through your map you can select any site of grace I've discovered.
However, there are some dungeons and other areas where this cannot be.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Is this me?
No.
This is me.
Oh my god.
I'm already so confused.
Too much information.
Wherever the wind takes you.
Oh my god.
Hero.
Thank you for five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Okay, I can figure this out.
I should get that real quick.
Am I even strengthening anything?
I need money.
No money.
Oh, someone said I should buy a torch.
Okay.
I'll buy that.
Purchase...
Torch.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Yay!
Go north?
Where's north?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
I'll go north.
There's no yellow line.
Anywhere.
Oh no, there is one.
Where's the yellow line pointing me?
Where are you taking me, my yellow line?
Oh, never mind.
Nowhere.
My yellow line disappeared.
Here.
Ethan, thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you.
North east here?
Oh my god.
What's this?
Seek tarnish.
Oh wait.
These guys.
First off, target lock.
Oh my god.
He's teaching me how to play.
I don't think he saw me.
Oh fuck, I still missed!
I won the fight.
I don't know the range.
Guys, I don't know the range.
I don't know.
I don't know the range!
It's my first time!
It worked in the end.
It still worked.
That's all that matters.
There's like some deers.
Wait, I heard some glowing stuff.
It still worked!
He doesn't know.
Stupid.
Nice.
I got some fruits too.
What is that sound?
You guys hear that?
Chemical, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the five gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, is it this?
What is this?
What is that?
I'm gonna break it.
What are you?
Defeat them.
Oh!
They replant.
That's fucking right.
Yoink.
Oh, it refills my flask.
Oh my god.
Why does that lag?
That's crazy.
Wait, materials.
Alright.
Absolute.
Thank you for the super chat.
I think you think most focused guard on the game.
This is where I can get res.
Uh...
Oh?
First off, life.
What's that mean?
Is he bad?
You think that's a bad person?
I can't tell.
There's a bonfire?
Oh, is it over there?
I think that's the bonfire, right?
Oh, it is.
Alright.
I'm going.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Told you Sekiro will be your...
Will be a training montage.
Is it even worth fighting these guys?
Seek rump.
Oh, seek buff.
I don't need a rest, to be fair.
Oh, set the fire?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, plot!
I was going to say, I was full HP.
Why would I need a...
Why would I need a set of the fire?
Which wife is this one?
See, I told you I'm not maidenless.
She came to me.
I did not seek her out.
Hello.
He telling my friends that I have a girlfriend?
Right in...
In this game?
People don't believe me.
I tell people you live in Canada, and they all laugh.
I feel this thing.
I offer you an accord.
Oh, what's wrong with your eye?
Have you heard of the finger major?
She goes to another school.
Two fingers.
Offering guidance.
And aid.
To the tarnished.
You're saying I'm ma...
No!
What?
You mean we're not official?
But...
I thought we were dating!
Turning rooms into strength.
You mean we were just friends?
You need only take me with you to the foot of the earth.
Oh, no.
She thought we were just friends.
Do I accept her?
She rejected me.
I should refuse, right?
Right.
Made it.
Accept her accord.
Okay, I'll accept.
And settled.
Summon me by grace.
To turn runes into strength.
Oh!
She helps me level up.
Oh, we're friends with benefits.
That's what it is, right?
Spectral steed whistle.
Oh, I have a horse now.
To traverse great distances.
It will summon a spectral steed.
Named Torrent.
Torrent has chosen you.
Now, I have a Honda.
Treat him with respect.
Uh...
She had a level up?
Should I turn your runes to strength?
Let my hand rest upon you.
Oh!
We're touching my hands.
Oh my god.
With the level up menu, you can spend runes to increase your attributes.
I'm too weak.
I need a 811.
Oh my god.
We're holding hands.
Guys.
Oh my gosh.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And she said we're just friends.
I refuse to believe it now.
Um...
Miss up.
But it will cost one flask.
Oh!
She can die?
Using order by pressing C.
Use items in pouch.
Four of these items can be used without opening the main menu.
On pouch, you can equip six items to your pouches.
Be up.
Okay.
We're not doing that.
We're rebinding that.
We're definitely rebinding those items.
All right.
Rebindings.
Okay.
Switch items.
Switch incantation.
Uh...
Where was the fucking thing that...
Wait.
Was that it?
Use item.
All right.
Where's my...
Where's the thing?
E up.
E switch.
Where's...
Where's the thing?
Equipment.
Equipment?
I wanna put my...
Put the horsey thing.
It's for the pouch?
Where the fuck is my pouch?
Oh, there you go.
Inventory.
You can browse items or drop them.
Okay.
There you go.
Mail display the tab with it.
Uh...
Itemstained can be marked with this.
Okay.
Information about...
There you go.
Wait.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Sorry.
A little special.
It's like...
I'm so confused.
Switch.
Okay.
There we go.
I was like...
Right side.
I know my left.
Left and right.
There...
There I go.
Don't worry, guys.
I know my left and right.
I said I was so fucking confused.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
This is a little awkward.
Because I can't rebind the other thing.
I...
Okay.
Wait.
I figured it out.
Okay.
If I do E...
And then...
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
There's the double jump.
Okay.
There it is.
All right.
There's that.
No.
I figured it out, guys.
And then...
There we go.
What's the top part?
What's the grace?
All right.
I think I can farm these guys.
What's he gonna do?
Kill me?
That's...
That's fucking right.
I kill you first.
Oh, wait.
I need that.
Oh, cool.
I got a helmet.
I got a helmet for it.
Okay.
I was like a little confused what that was.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm barely understanding my own controls.
Oh, he's...
That guy blows a horn.
Can't blow the horn if I kill him first.
No horn blowing for you.
Don't worry.
He doesn't know.
Do you think he knows?
I told you he doesn't know.
I...
I told you, guys.
What was the...
Just the wind.
That's right.
It was me.
The wind.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
He doesn't know either.
Hello.
That's fucking right.
Got your knees.
Damn, that's a strong fucking wind right there.
Oh, wait.
I think that guy must be really strong.
He has, like, all the armor.
All right.
Please press car 1 closer.
Please, Toki.
That's all we ask you.
Just go a little closer.
You mean left click.
What key is that?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
There's two of you.
But what if there was...
Oh, yes.
Nice.
Guys, okay.
I don't think he...
Guys.
How did he go?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
How did he know?
Oh.
Guys, appraise the message.
Appraise the message.
Appraise it.
Signed appraising.
They said...
I have so many messages.
Appraise...
Guys, I have so many.
I have so many.
Just one appraise.
Oh, I forgot.
I don't remember how to use the flask.
Oh, my God.
What button is that?
I...
Alright.
Okay, I'm back.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
Why couldn't you appraise?
Oh, my God.
Please.
I can't...
There you go.
That guy was scary.
That...
No.
No tips.
Okay.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
I lived.
I used a bit too many flasks.
But I live.
I just don't know my timings, okay?
I just...
I just don't know the timing for this.
There's so many.
Jesus Christ.
He has a wolf?
Okay.
This might not be a...
This might be bad.
Like, I could get so many kills if I do this.
Oh.
So many kills.
One kill.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
He hit me?
What's your...
What's your range?
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's fine.
I need to know, like, the range for this.
There we go.
We're fine.
See?
We're so healthy.
Yeah.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
Your range is insane.
Alright.
I have one flasks left.
But it was so worth it.
Oh.
There's, like, a little tunnel here.
So worth it.
No enemy ahead.
Oh, man.
Oh, he's right.
Nice.
What did I get?
With a knife, you can use ashes of water.
Grant your arms new skills at Sight of Grace.
You can only have one skill.
Any skill previously had will be removed.
Chabby, prepare for the hell with Toki.
Toki out here trying to test in the message appraisal build.
Shake my head.
Alright.
You can use ashes of water.
Grant affinities to your arm.
What does that mean?
The way you can alter boost attributes and armaments type determines what affinities it can have.
Like, those cannot be granted.
I-I don't understand.
I-I read it, but I-I don't understand.
I-and so-oh, it custom-oh, it customizes my weapon.
Okay.
I was like, that makes zero sense to me.
And I change it with the woman, right?
With my friends with benefits?
She'll change it for me, right?
Jump attack.
Heavier weapons, the better.
Okay, you're just-I can tell you're, like, a sword-what was it called?
A, uh, uh, Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're a-you're a great sword.
You're a-you're-what are they called?
When-when they-they're, like, the-the one that preaches to use that certain weapon.
No, not-yeah, great sword purist.
I know what you are.
Oh my god, was that it?
Did I do it?
Okay, watch this.
Nice.
Oh, you can't do shit.
Oh shit, you can't do shit!
No.
Wait, I-but I jumped!
I jumped!
Okay.
Oh nice, I got healed.
Let's go, someone found my message.
Wait, let me just-if I put multiple messages, then people-
Action.
Uh...
Yeah, thanks.
Right here.
Oh, loot in the- Carriage.
Okay.
Engagement?
I'm gonna engagement farm.
Alright, love.
We're straight to the point.
I'm engagement farming, guys.
Oh, what's in here?
Oh, nice.
I got a fill.
Your greed sickens me.
No, no, no!
Look.
I'll give like a good tip too.
Guys, don't worry.
I'll give like...
Enemy a hand.
There we go.
What a good tip.
Now they'll know.
Now they'll know there's an enemy ahead, guys.
That's so helpful.
Perfect.
Look at that.
I'm here to help my fellow tarnish.
Our materials.
Oh, nice.
I'm just helping my fellow tarnish.
Time for stealth.
They're all dead.
Oh, there's like those guys.
I don't know.
These guys are freaky.
Oh, there's another carriage.
Jump.
What's in here?
Oh, I got a greatsword.
Oh my god, the greatsword Paris right here is freaking out right now.
I got the thing he wanted.
Guys, you're not supposed to praise now!
Full HP.
You gotta wait.
Oh, okay.
Now I can level up.
Alright, guys.
What build do I do?
What's my build?
God, I have the praise now.
Oh wait, is that strength?
That's what I like.
Oh wait, no.
That's not strength.
Wait, that's HP.
I was like.
Okay.
Easy strength.
Swing.
Big stick.
Dex quick.
Slash east.
Faith healing.
Soldier.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Zero deaths.
Okay, wait.
Actually, do I need to do other stuff?
Uh...
Do I need to...
What's ashes of war?
The grand skills.
Inevent.
I assume I don't do it for these yet, right?
I assume I don't yet.
I'll just wait for that.
Wait, he's back.
Oh shit, I accidentally reset.
Oops.
Legion Jack Dragoo is logging into the game, standing around the summon signs waiting for their signal.
Thank you for the super chat episode.
Thank you, thank you.
Stormgate.
Try defeating one by one.
Oh, are these guys?
Oh hey.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Okay, he can't...
No, I haven't fought him yet!
What?
I haven't even fought him yet!
It's not even...
He's not even there!
Mahdi...
Mahdi, Mahdi, Mahdi!
Mahdi, Mahdi!
Rarity to help us he's...
Why did you...
I haven't even fought him!
Why did you appraise?!
Okay...
He's just...
He's just standing there...
Menacing to me.
Alright.
You think I can, like, lead him down here?
Can you go past it?
Hello?
Hey.
Friend?
Bro, what the... Oh, shit!
Oh, you heal me after I got hit by the bow!
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna lead him outside.
Okay, now fight him.
Okay... Guys,
now is the time!
Now is the... Oh, nice, okay.
Okay, nice.
Now... Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh, shit, okay!
Oh, fuck!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Somehow, I'm okay.
Bro, okay, you were, like, a little too late with that, but that's okay.
That's okay.
That is 100% okay.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Okay, I did it.
I... I did it!
Guys, I'm making a new build.
It's called the influencer build.
It's...
That's the... That's the... The streamer build.
I told you!
I'm pioneering a new build!
I'm undoing it!
I'm doing it!
Messages...
This is near the Predator build.
Try.
Try, hero.
Upvote this.
Oh, shit, I blocked.
This is my upvote build right here.
I knew it would work.
Bro, okay, there's too many arrows.
What do you want me to do here?
Okay.
Jesus!
Oh my god, I have to jump.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I don't care about using... Okay, I need to... What?!
Where did you come from?!
Okay.
I have to jump in.
This is dumb.
There we go.
Alright, I gotta kill him.
I'm coming over.
There we go.
Why has nobody ever used this build before?
It's so strong.
We'll replenish your flash.
The number of attacks can replenish varies.
You cannot... Nice.
Okay, there were like 200 million arrows.
I have to block.
I got a golden rune.
I got a helmet.
The strongest build.
Gee, I wonder.
Guys, it's so easy.
Just be a streamer.
Just be a content creator.
It's so easy.
I need healing.
You put on a password.
You should make a video about the content creator build.
Just stream.
I don't need a horse.
I fight everyone.
Alright.
I need healing.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Wait a minute!
He blew his horn!
That's cheating!
I say it as I'm abusing heals.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
I'll slash you one by one.
Oh my god.
That's not good.
I'm fucking staggered.
Bye.
I'm okay.
No archer head.
Oh, that's good to know.
No way he said that.
Can't believe he tried to outplay me.
Alright.
See ya.
That should be everybody, right?
I mean, it's good for a level up here.
Alright, alright, alright.
I won't abuse my messages anymore.
I just wanted to test out the content creator build, okay?
I wanted to know if it works.
And we discovered that it works.
I won't...
For now, I won't abuse them.
It's not my fault that it's such a strong build, guys.
Is it truly my fault?
If there's a way to cheese, you know I take advantage of it.
The only way I can heal is to have messages.
It's not my fault, dude.
It's...
Yeah, it's in the game.
A wolf?
Rain ahead, but didn't expect a wolf?
Up dog ahead.
Oh.
Whoa.
Don't worry.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Come on.
Get a little closer.
Get a little...
I'm ready.
There we go.
That's right.
Come back.
Oh, you're gonna walk away?
I don't need arrows.
Oh, you pussy.
I thought you were was.
Are you a pussy?
Oh god, we're making her immortal.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
I thought I was fighting wolves.
Not fucking pussycats.
Get over here!
Oh my god.
Why were they so afraid of these wolves?
That's fucking right.
Oh, you're gonna walk away?
He's just like, okay, I'm...
Okay, I'll leave.
Okay, leave.
He saw his friend's dad and he's like, alright.
Nice to see you, sir.
Whoa!
Nice.
I'm so good at this.
Oh, wait.
I kicked the baby.
Wait, what is that?
Is that nothing?
Oh.
Oh, I had to destroy it.
I was like, why can't I do anything?
What's over there?
Oh.
There's a campfire.
Okay.
Yay!
Wait, I want free stuff.
Oh, there's another woman.
Wait, whoops.
Wait, I want to...
...steal his stuff first.
Well, it's not stealing if he's already dead.
Hello.
Lovable sword.
Angel.
Oh, angel.
Oh my god.
You must be truly beautiful.
It's...
Taken...
Taken and stuck...
To the spider.
It's called grave robin?
It's okay, I'm British.
Did you know...
You're grafted by the spider.
You become a chrysalid.
It's quite a lark when you think about it.
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, I'm not cheesing.
I just want people to know.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I need a note.
Door...
Brian F was right about you.
What did I do?
What did I even do?
I'm playing...
I'm just playing the game.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
Do I not have it?
Do I...
Do I not have maiden?
Are you serious?
Monarch.
Lord.
I'm looking for maiden.
No maiden.
No!
There must be maiden!
There's no way!
No you deserve...
I deserve maidens!
I have...
Okay.
I have to un...
I have to unlock maiden?
That's it.
People will believe me when I...
People will believe me.
Lover.
I'm gonna tell everybody at school.
I'm gonna...
I'm telling everyone at school.
A very truthful message.
Wait, I can talk to her more?
Try head...
Butthole.
Francisca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Phoebe, thank you for the 10 gift of ships.
Enticed by the one in the white mask, I suppose.
Well, you've come to be one with the spider.
Yeah?
That makes us two peas in a pod.
But I don't have your courage.
It's scary, you know, having your arms cut off.
Or legs.
I mean, yeah.
I mean, that's pretty painful, too.
Like everyone else, but I'm just too scared.
I'm nothing but a craven.
I think she's Scottish.
A jellyfish.
Oh, I know.
Can you take this little one along with you?
Oh?
Oh, I got a jellyfish!
The poor thing deserves someone brave and a nicer.
What does that do?
And...
The spirits look rather fondly upon you.
It'll be glad...
Make...
Thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Welsh?
Is she Welsh?
You can use ash to summon various spirits.
Typically...
Consumes...
You can only summon one type of spirit.
Oh!
To the merchant?
Why is she the merchant?
What would the merchant do for me?
Oh, go back to the church?
Okay.
Oh, I got another charge.
Yes.
Alright.
Let me, like, make sure it's just that.
Talk to Melania?
Melina?
Hello.
Oh.
Hello, my friends with benefits.
This tiny golden aura is the grace of the earth tree.
This light...
Once shone in the eyes of your tarnished brethren.
But now...
It is all that guides you.
Also, I hear...
You can see them, can't you?
The rays of grace...
That guide you through your burden.
She levels me up!
That's a benefit!
I don't understand!
Do they go to the church?
Oh, back to the merchant?
A fragment of the shattered Elden Ring.
If the rays of grace signal the castle, then the Elden Ring beckons you.
As an ally by Pact, I pray that you are fit to face the challenge presented...
I think we are dragons.
This is a team effort.
Oh, can I level up now?
To strength.
Let my hand rest upon you.
For but a moment...
Share them with you.
Alright, what do we do next, guys?
Ooh, I have a lot!
Your ambitions.
The principles you would follow.
Oh my gosh, she held...
I love how she holds my hand every time.
More...
More HP?
Okay.
I could do another one.
I'm pretty sure.
And then...
Dexterity or...
Or heals?
HP or heals?
Or strength?
Oh, sorry.
That's two things.
Sorry.
I meant...
Max is a 20?
Okay.
Alright.
We'll get to 20 first.
Bye.
I held her hand and then she...
She got Thanos'd.
Cause I guess it was just too much, I guess.
I...
Well, excuse me!
I guess holding my hand was just a little too much.
Where the fuck is the church?
Is this a...
Oh, there she is.
Excuse me, princess.
I washed my hands.
Maybe it...
Oh!
Wife number three!
Hello?
Oh my god!
You're the lady with all the hands!
You know what they say about a lady with four arms.
A pleasure to meet thee, Tarnished.
I am the witch Renna.
Okay, I'm...
I can tell the Tarnished hurtling about atop a spectral steed.
And upon looking into the matter, the talk I surmise is of thee.
Thou art possessed of the power, no?
To call forth a spectral steed named Torrent.
What?
I can call...
Oh, yeah, I can.
As I had hoped, I was entrusted this for thee, by Torrent's former master.
Oh?
Oh, it's the calling bell!
Yeah!
Oh, now I get worse!
It is a battle of calling forth spirits.
Summon them with it.
From ash and return to the earth tree.
The spirits will obey thine command, but briefly.
As they recall battles past.
Now it is thine...
To do with as thou wishest.
Okay.
People will...
Oh, my...
People in school will believe me.
Behold!
Lover!
I'm gonna tell everybody at school.
Forgive mine intrusion tarnished.
I doubt we shall again meet.
But all the same, learn well the lands between.
He checks out.
Before the tarnished tire of obeisance to the two fingers.
Oh!
Goodbye!
She didn't even touch my hand!
The picture didn't happen.
I left a message.
That's the picture.
The picture is my message.
You just gotta be there, bro.
You just had to be there.
Alright.
Ooh, I don't like that it's night time.
Let me make it day real quick.
Let me...
Morning!
She just goes to a different school!
Wait, why is it still night time?
Yeah.
Yeah, but I don't need summons.
I'm not a...
I need summons.
I can't...
I saw four people.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I saw four and I got a little scared.
I...
Switch.
This?
What is this?
Summons three lone wolves.
Oh, I don't have enough for that.
Is that it?
Doki meds wore off and the third...
Disappeared.
No, I took my meds and she's gone!
How could this happen to me?
Wait, how do I use my summons?
I can only use it?
Give me a sec.
Wait, what?
Oh!
It's only in certain places!
Goddammit!
I did all that for nothing!
That's fine.
Oh, hey.
Noink.
He's gonna turn around.
Don't worry, I got this.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki's maiden was so strong.
Man simply banished in presence.
Okay.
Watch this.
Turn around.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-ba-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da Alright,
they turned around.
Alright, nice.
Wait, what's that over there?
Oh, we accidentally pressed my map.
Cause I was like, what the fuck actually marked that?
I was like, what is that?
Okay.
Uh, let's follow the path, I guess.
I can't believe this.
Seek rump.
Oh my god, is there another maiden?
Is there another...
Yeah, but I can gain, like, more, uh, more XP.
No sword fighter ahead.
I trust that.
Let there be circling around, but be wary of group.
Oh, I killed him.
I think mouse and keyboard is fine.
Oh, there they are.
I don't know, maybe controller is easier?
I don't know.
I can't tell if it is easier or not.
He doesn't know.
See?
I told you he didn't know.
Wait, there's a blue Acon!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
You got this, bro!
I
believe in you!
Oh shit, bro!
I think I might need to help the bro out.
I...
Guys, I don't think bro is doing so well.
It's okay, we did it.
Please.
She's just a child.
Watch this.
What?
Oh, I did not...
Sorry, not...
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Come on!
What?
What hit me?!
Oh fuck!
Okay!
Okay, I did not expect that!
Oh no, not him!
Not this fucker!
Jesus Christ!
There you go!
Okay, I don't think the other guy saw me though, so we should be fine.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I have no idea where the big guy is.
I don't know!
Okay.
I need to find the other guy.
Okay, there he is.
Okay, now I know.
Okay, watch this!
They literally explode!
I didn't know they have a fucking ballistic!
Get outta here!
Tarnished, you don't have...
Beware!
Thank you!
Thank you for letting me know about this guy!
I really appreciate it!
I missed!
How?
How did...
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Stop moving!
That was the true maiden all along!
Okay.
We did it!
What the fuck?
How did he do that?
I wanna read this message!
No close corner paddles ahead!
Okay.
They have a ballistic!
Wait, what if I...
Wait, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Behold, morning.
Okay.
No enemies ahead.
There we go.
Nice.
That's crazy!
What's over here?
Wait, why did a lot of people die here?
Wait a minute!
Wait.
What?
There's so...
There's so many people dying here!
Get those messages ready!
First off...
Guys, I'm so lazy!
Heads!
Just asking politely.
What killed them?
What- Nice!
Alright.
Seek good luck.
Mist or Beast.
Oh!
Her!
Wait, that's the guy that my dad keeps dying to!
That's him!
Wait, Gold Summon?
What is that?
Help me, oh help me on.
That's the first one!
Oh, I should level her.
I should level up the Dragoon.
You're right.
Alright, oh, I'll talk to her.
Me?
I'm searching.
For my purpose.
Given to me by my mother inside the earth tree.
Ok, Dragoon's lock-in.
Doki put down lock-in.
Make it multi-player.
But that makes it more fun!
It makes it more fun when it's not password.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yet can offer no guidance.
I am no maiden.
Wait, yes you are?
I see you for who you are.
A maiden.
I see you.
Don't worry.
To strength.
Let my hand rest upon you.
Oh.
Okay.
Share them with me.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time.
It's time to have my first death.
She could be our maiden.
Alright, it's time.
Have I learned anything?
Okay.
To be fair.
Is it truly my fault if I'm getting enabled?
Is it?
Oh, there he is.
That's the guy my dad kept dying to.
I'm not foul.
I'm just cheesing a little bit.
No, he didn't beat him.
I beat him.
The wing will be in a light of the flame.
Let it be Margaret the fowl.
Okay.
Jelly.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
I was trying to use my jellyfish.
Give me a sec.
Jellyfish.
Okay.
I need to know his patterns though.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
There's a pattern.
Oh, okay, that's good.
He just... fights him.
What?!
I run!
Okay, nice.
Wait, I'm not using... Wait, how am I... Why am I using my arrows?!
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
Go, jellyfish!
Take that shit!
Take it!
I'm slowly walking over!
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's not good.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god!
Oh god, fuck.
Nice.
Oh, that's a stagger!
Oh, no.
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Go, jellyfish!
Yes!
Die for me!
Die for your... your master!
Oh shit!
Keep dying!
Oh my god, I did not realize the heals for that was... I swear to god!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
I
can't!
Okay, don't... Alright, if you'll be alive, you'll drop any runes by the site and die again.
Okay, we know that.
Okay, okay.
I'll focus up.
I... I'll focus up now.
Okay, I have to, like, figure out his patterns.
Don't worry.
Go, jellyfish!
Ow!
Where did my runes go?
You go do your thing.
I'm gathering my runes real quick.
This?
There it is.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
Okay, I have to figure out the pattern for him.
Oh, no!
I need to figure out my... I need to remember my stamina, too.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, no!
No!
Heal!
I need to go fast.
Okay.
Okay, he's... Oh my god.
Jesus!
Oh, where am I?
I did not, like, spam my bros.
Makes me want to spam it so bad.
Oh god.
No.
Okay, I dodged that.
Oh my god.
What?!
Oh, nice, he's gonna kill my squid.
Wait, I thought you were focusing on my squid.
What happened?
Oh fuck.
Oh my god, Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm okay.
Are you serious?
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's so hard to time the rolls.
It's always so close.
Sorry, I meant jellyfish.
Oh.
It's so hard to time the rolls.
Wait, my dev counter's not working.
What if it just stays there forever?
Wait, my dev counter actually isn't working.
I don't understand.
Maybe it's here.
How is it still zero devs?
Oh.
Okay, now it should work.
Did it work?
Oh, there we go.
Now it should say two.
There we go.
There, I fixed it.
Yeah, I fixed it.
All right.
I believe.
Go jellyfish, go!
Okay.
Jesus!
All right.
I'll figure this out.
Oh.
I think for me, it's more so like his- the rolls is so delayed too sometimes.
Like, oh, I didn't get roll abs.
I wanted to like figure out the roll mechanic.
I was trying to figure it out.
For these foolish provisions to rest.
How do you do so much damage?
I done so much damage!
Oh.
you roll on release?
Not on press?
Oh, that's... bullshit.
Shit!
Oh my god, you roll... Okay, I just realized you roll on release.
I... I... I just realized.
I... I just realized.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
There we go.
I didn't know that.
Okay.
Alright.
Jellyfish, please!
He's right here!
Fight him!
At least now I know that.
Jesus, his tail got me.
Okay.
His tail got me.
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot to pick up my thing.
But it doesn't matter.
Anyway.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
I didn't know this attack.
I didn't know yet.
What the fuck?!
I will land!
I don't need the free summon.
I don't need him.
I could do... I just need my good old Val Jellyfish.
Jellyfish!
Well, I lost my streamer build, but I don't want to abuse it more.
I'm trying... I'm not... Look, I'm trying to not abuse it too much.
Okay?
We almost first try with it and I realized how broken it was.
I realized... It was very broken, so I'm trying not to abuse that shit.
I literally... Oh, I fuck!
I fuck air suppressor!
I don't know why!
I was like, I need to reload my sword.
Okay.
I don't know why.
I was like, time to reload my sword.
I don't need to reload my sword.
Hmm.
Okay.
I did it!
OMG I did IT!
I did the thing!
Oh my god, I leave now!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
God damn it, not nice.
Not nice.
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh, what?
Nice.
For me.
Jesus.
Oh my god, how many?
For me.
Oh.
No!
I don't know.
I thought it would be cool when I jumped.
I really did.
No!
You're pressing the wrong time!
I rolled backwards instead of right side.
No!
I was like, let me roll backwards.
That's how you do it.
I got two appraisals off the bat too.
Jellyfish!
We can do this, you and me.
I'll just do this entire run with just jellyfish summons too.
That's how much I'm gonna gain.
Guys.
This is gonna be a jellyfish only run.
I can do it.
Face.
Jelly buddy.
I think I can do a jellyfish only run.
That's possible.
Spongebob.
I can do it.
Oh, shit!
My jelly bro.
He's like 2.5 for me.
Warrior loves to have aehman.
Jesus, that's actually cheating.
Oh my god, I don't think my bro is having a good time right now.
Okay.
Oh no.
No.
Roll, keep rolling!
It's okay.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, this stupid little dagger shit.
Rolling!
Stupid delay attack.
Jesus.
Okay.
Oh my god.
But, yes, you can keep rolling.
But what if I kept tired from rolling?
Yes!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Just keep rolling.
Oh my god, we did it.
We did it.
See, guys.
I don't abuse my content creator.
My content creator build that much.
Fear of the night.
Alright.
Nice.
First try.
Hello, I did it.
Are you proud of me?
I've been...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There is but one other thing.
But what is it?
I can do to offer you guidance.
I can take you to the round table hole.
Gathering place.
Of tarnished champions.
Guided.
By grace.
Oh?
Very well.
What is this place?
Let my hand rest upon you.
For but a moment.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
I think, thank you.
Not gonna lie.
I thought you'd be stuck here longer.
Nice.
Nice job.
I did it.
We did it, guys.
This was a group effort.
Oh, there's a place where tarnished gathered.
Guided by grace.
I bet I'm, like, raising the player count right now.
What was this build?
I have, like, so many tragoons just chilling at the messages right now.
Like...
Combust parade on the premise.
And...
Do a pack of non-aggression.
Um...
The round tell you behold is located outside.
And fast travel grace is the only means.
Use the map to travel there.
What's this?
I have an army.
Press.
Oh!
I mean, I can level up right now, right?
So we just max out to 20.
Wait!
Can I max out to 20 already?
Oh my god, how much did I have?
Oh, that's a lot!
My respect for you will go extremely high if you also use Aurelia as your only summon.
Also, you can check the full description of all items by pressing R on the keyboard.
Uh, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Cenk.
That's right.
We'll only do...
We'll only do jellyfish run.
This is a jellyfish only run.
This is a jellyfish content creator build.
It only makes sense!
I don't really need summons when I just have messages.
Like...
And I...
And I have, like, messages.
Okay.
Going for endurance and...
Endurance and dexterity?
My jellybro.
Why are you mad, huh?
Why are you mad?
Did I wake you up because I was screaming?
That's on you for sleeping here.
Oh my god.
Even he is ready to fight.
Here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This guy beat...
Yeah, I beat Tree Center.
Yeah!
And I didn't abuse level ups.
I just fought.
I just went straight for him.
All me.
Can I level anything up?
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
What can I do here?
Hello.
Oh, I see you've just arrived.
Welcome to the round table hold.
I'm Corrin, a man of the cloth.
Oh, he's not...
Oh wait, Margaret.
Oh yes, sorry.
I meant Margaret.
Granted us by the two fingers.
And explore the secrets of the golden order.
So that one day, if a tarnished of the round table hold should become Elden Lord.
Huh?
I might counsel them.
Ensuring order regains its proper form.
Why are you locked up, bro?
Lighting rule over men.
By the way, do you still see it?
The guidance of grace.
Raven, well, thank you for...
Yeah, I see it.
Oh, is it the yellow thing?
You, most tarnished are blind to it these days.
You are something of a rare breed.
Well, what do you say?
Care to learn an incantation of the two fingers?
The two fingers?
Okay.
Bro, that's kinky.
Alright.
Okay.
It has a small amount of HP.
Cures poison.
Catch flame.
Oh, he teaches magic.
I don't need this, right?
We don't...
We're not magic users.
But we don't really need it.
We don't really need it.
Do anyone I have to talk to?
Hello, Diallos.
One of one's house holds little import in these lands.
By the way...
Have you met a young woman named Lanya on your travels?
She's my servant.
But fickle as the wind.
Take your eyes off her for but a moment and she's good as gone.
If you find her...
Please be sure to tell me.
Okay.
Oh.
Guess I can never read that.
I wanna read this.
Why would you put it up on the chair?
Ah, regret.
Why?
First off...
Fingered...
Wait.
Let's see.
Messages.
No, Hen.
Who are you?
Oh, this is a rare occasion.
I can't remember the last time a new Tarnished made their way to the round table.
Very well.
As your senior...
No head?
It is safe here.
You may let down your guard.
Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Top cap for vigor is 40.
Hard cap is 60.
Praise the fingers.
Okay, we'll go there soon.
Alright.
What else is this?
They're here.
What's this?
Door.
What's wrong?
What do you want?
Okay.
What's that?
Be wary of dung.
Didn't expect a lovable sword.
What?
What are these?
He's just an edgelord?
Ooh.
Should I buy anything or no?
Answers request for summoning from hunters.
When invaded, request the aid of...
For summoning...
Yeah.
Should I buy anything or no?
Shop?
Yeah, but should I buy anything in the shop or no?
What's the bell bearing?
Oh, are these PvP items?
Oh.
I see.
Try finger butthole.
Dark, thank you.
Super shopping thing.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, bell bearings opens new shop items?
Should I...
Should I give it to them?
Do I have any?
Oh, I don't have any.
Okay, never mind.
Goodbye.
I don't have anything.
I like how they offer it to me.
I feel like if I don't have any, it shouldn't show up.
Wait, what?
Why is it always suffering?
Okay, if I'm jumping down, I'm putting a message down.
I'm putting...
If I...
Time for healing.
If you're gonna...
I'm just saying, if you're gonna fucking make me jump, I'm fucking putting a message.
Like...
This is on you.
Message.
Time for healing.
Jesus.
Here we go.
Oh.
He looks mad.
Wait, I can't summon a jellyfish.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I fucked up.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why can't I...
What the...
What the fuck?
Okay, guys.
Okay, you fuckers.
What the hell?
Message was a, message was a freeze.
Okay, you fucks.
I'll do one more.
I'll do one more try.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for the message of praise, guys.
Thanks.
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate the appraisal.
You guys did it.
You guys... Thanks, guys.
Thanks.
Alright.
I don't think I'm strong enough for him.
We're trying to die in the more convenient way.
I guess I don't... Oh, wait.
My depth doesn't count.
I just realized.
My... Yeah.
My depth doesn't count for him.
Yippee!
Yay!
My depth doesn't count.
Yippee!
Technically, I didn't die.
No two-handed head.
What?
A little sword ahead.
My new face.
No matter.
It's all the same.
Lay out your arms.
Let's get smithing.
What?
Strength in armament?
Oh, I don't have the money.
Because I died.
Boss's blood loss buildup.
Do I even upgrade anything?
I see you've noticed the chains.
Nothing special.
I'm a prisoner and these are my chains.
I'm trapped by the hold.
I'm dying smithing for you fools.
That's all there is to it.
Sell?
What do I sell?
I have so much stuff.
I don't even know what to sell.
Oh, do I sell?
Maybe I should sell equipment.
Uh...
I don't even know what my equipment is right now.
Helmet.
3.1.
Wait.
Should I change my outfit?
Do I have golden runes?
Rune fragment.
I have this.
This is super weird.
So I'll just sell these.
Because I have two of the same.
Let's see.
Oh, I should sort it.
Sort by item type.
There we go.
Uh...
I'm just selling these guys.
For now.
Because I have the same.
Any gold runes?
Do I have gold runes?
This one?
Okay.
They're not anything, right?
They're not anything important, right?
Envy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I'll just sell them.
Okay.
Should be able to afford strength then.
Is it worth strengthening my sword right now?
Or what?
Or should I just...
Try and find...
Yeah?
Okay, I'll strengthen.
Okay.
Additional item?
What do I need?
Oh, that ash is a war.
Or nah.
Nah?
I don't know.
I don't know if I have any.
Oh, okay.
I don't.
That shit.
No.
Don't read too much into it.
I have no grudge against you.
My being a prisoner is no fault of yours.
Besides, I don't mind smithing.
Despite my differences, the weapons get stronger all the same.
Even time.
Technique never fails.
Besides, it helps me forget...
The sheer terror of her.
Who's her?
Who is she?
I don't know who she is.
You won't tell me.
Oops, sorry.
I have to tab up.
My GoXLR has this issue where, like, if I mute myself and I go unmute, it, like, sometimes lowers itself's...
its volume.
So I have to, like, re-up it.
Okay.
It's over here.
Behold, hero.
Is that a maiden?
Still no behind.
Look!
Another one.
If only I had...
If only I had a lover.
Wait.
I can do a gesture, right?
I can do a gesture with that, right?
If only I had...
A lover.
And then...
Why do I put a gesture?
I need...
I need to know.
This is very important.
F?
Okay, nice.
Jump with joy!
Prayer.
The best part.
There you go.
Greetings, great champion called by grace.
I am Fia.
Circumstances have compelled my stay at the round table hold.
Great champion.
No, I'm praying for it.
I'm praying for it to work.
Briefly.
Perhaps you might share with me some of your lifely vigor.
And your stout-heartedness.
Doing so will grant me the warmth.
Oh my god, is this where I'm gonna get a maiden?
We'll bear a buldekin's blessing.
Wife number four.
Where I come from, it is a sacred act.
Oh my god.
Yes, hold me.
We're going to second base.
Guys.
I knew it.
See?
The prayer worked.
Guys.
You're...
Very warm.
Oh!
Felt light up inside you.
Was a buldekin's blessing.
My HP!
Though it is but a fleeting thing, I am afraid.
Come back to me.
Should you require another?
Wait.
I will take you in my arms.
My HP!
How much did she take?
How much?
Fuck god, I got cooties.
God.
Oh my god.
Wait.
My kakuris.
Oh my god.
I can use an item to get rid of it.
Wait.
Let me put another message.
Uh.
Is there...
Ah.
Woman.
Sinner.
This is a story.
Three parts.
This is a story right here.
I committed sin.
I knew it.
My body is for God and God only.
I betrayed Jesus and my Lord.
I knew it.
This body is for God only.
Mirror, mirror.
Wait.
How do I get rid of it?
What does she even do to me?
What do I get out of that?
Did I get anything out of it?
What is this?
Use FP to temporary boost poise.
Is that it?
Oh, but it's only temporary.
Yeah, she gave you cooties.
Yeah, I know that.
But like, did she give me anything else?
Try door.
Fucking liar.
Bad message.
Oh, it turns the debuff off.
Okay.
I'll use it now.
Should I use it now?
Yeah, okay.
Did it just take my magic?
Lover ahead.
Which way?
Too high up.
What?
My God.
There's a lover right here?
No!
Where is she?
I learned nothing.
No, I learned.
I learned I committed sin.
Oh, I'm not.
I have to complete a quest.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Alright, I think I explored everywhere here.
I guess I just go this way now.
The door.
Oh, never mind.
I guess I don't go this way.
I don't do that.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
How do I get out of here?
I feel like I'm stuck here.
Map?
Oh, I just have to leave.
Oh, okay.
Where was I?
Here?
That's where I killed Margaret.
I teleport from the map.
Absolute.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
This is how I feel to the male fantasy.
Did I do this or...
Oh, no.
I already did.
Okay.
Wait, can I level up or no?
No, I don't have a lot.
Hello.
I'm here now.
Hello, everybody.
Anything here that I can steal?
Any enemies?
Hello?
Anyone here?
That wants to fuck me up?
Oh.
I could go down, technically.
I could go down here.
Oh, wait.
There's a resting point.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, Dr. Nick.
I could go this way.
There's a body.
Yoink.
Remini summons signs of players.
Gold signs indicate red signs indicate the multiplayer session will begin once I type has been you will take the role of host of fingers.
Oh, this is where I can do multiplayer.
Okay, but I can also get invaded.
So, like, let's not do that.
Let's not do that, guys.
I think I don't want to get invaded.
I...
I go down?
Or is that too scary?
How did he die?
Oh, shit.
He tried to wolverine his way out.
Ew!
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
You there.
Come over here, would you?
Be wary of thief.
Dastard ahead, therefore attacking.
Okay, but, like, he seems like a nice guy.
I don't know.
I think they're lying.
I think he's a nice...
He could be a nice guy.
You don't know that.
He can't...
Come over here, won't you?
No thief ahead.
He seems trustworthy.
You're...
You're tarnished, aren't you?
Yeah?
I would advise against taking the main gate into the castle.
It's tightly guarded by hardened old hands.
Try the opening right here.
The guards don't know about it.
You'll breach the castle undetected.
Can't believe you caught Doki engaging perimeter hugs and...
No, I'll use the main gate.
I trust you.
But I'm gonna use the main gate.
I totally trust you, though, bro.
Bro, don't worry.
I'm gonna believe it.
Fair enough.
You certainly don't have to trust me.
Wait, I can run all messes?
If you must go through the gates, I'll signal them to open.
Wait, that's possible?
Oh my god, I'm pretty sure I did more than ten.
Guys, this does not look good.
Why are there dead bodies around?
Oh, golden rune.
Oh.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay.
Um.
Don't worry.
Thanks, guys.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
I can outrun this.
Oh, fuck!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, no!
He told me I got the lion!
What do you mean there's a lion?
Get a fish!
Get over here!
Nobody ever tells me about the lion!
You ran in there so fast.
Oh, my God!
The lion!
The lion, the witch, and the war!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, my God!
It's Aslan!
Mill Street!
Okay.
Who gave this lion a knife?
It's like giving him a fucking gun!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
Jesus Christ.
Bro, my jellyfish bro is gonna fucking kill him before I can do anything.
You know what?
You can... Oh, my God.
Just die from poison.
Yeah!
Let's high five!
High five!
Jesus Christ.
Why didn't no one tell me about the lion?
Lion!
What?
I did it.
No one ever talks about the fucking lion!
There has to be, like, a place.
I didn't think you would go for it.
Wait, can I go here?
I'm scared.
I'm lying on the right.
Can I go here?
Oh, hello, jellyfish.
Oh, there's a heal, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Thank god.
Yay!
Alright, I must have enough.
I do not have enough.
Never mind.
Alright, I guess we go up.
There's no way the lion respawns.
There's no fucking way.
I went through so much.
There's no way.
There's no way he's back.
Thank god, he's gone.
Oh, thank god, he's gone forever.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Wait, wrong path?
Oh, I missed an item next to the grace.
Where is it?
Where is the item?
I don't see no item.
Watch out for the lion.
Alright, I guess I'll grab this.
Oh!
That's a talisman.
Wait, is that the tree sentinel?
Oh, equip it?
Okay.
What is that, anyway?
What was it?
That I found?
What the fuck did I- Oh, it's this.
Boost lightning.
Wait, I can't equip- wait.
I couldn't- what is it for?
Is it equipment?
Oh, there it is.
Wanna go outside?
Wait, I didn't wanna go outside.
We're leaving.
Alright.
Sorry.
Dad wanted to go outside.
Bro, I'm not even fighting him yet!
Storm hill.
Is this part of the story, though?
How did he die?
Nah, nah, blood stings.
So...
Oh, it's for later?
Okay.
I'll go up the hill.
I'll go up the hill, then.
Woah!
Let's go!
I'm glad, like, sprinting...
Sprinting doesn't, like, take up my stamina, which is nice.
I like that.
Oh, hey, nice.
Got Lily.
I...
I try to reload my sword.
I don't know why I keep doing that!
I keep wanting to reload my sword!
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
I didn't know!
Oh, my God.
He has a big-ass axe.
He has...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna run.
Too much Marvel ride.
I'm gonna restart.
Don't get to go through so much recently.
This ain't much, but...
Aw, thank you, Lise, for the...
Super!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Alright, let's...
Let's rest up a little.
Uh...
I don't have to ask any...
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
We got this.
Okay, now that I know...
To not engage that...
It's fine.
I'm gonna summon the jellyfish.
My pal.
Do your thing.
That's right!
Do your thing, my guy!
I believe!
Shoot your goo!
Shoot it!
Okay, you're missing.
I can see...
Where are you shooting?
Where is he shooting?
Oh, my...
Okay, my jellyfish is a little special.
I don't know where he's shooting, guys.
I...
Don't know.
Jellyfish, please!
Please, jellyfish!
Oh, my God.
I don't know where he's trying to shoot.
I don't know where he's trying to do.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
He doesn't know.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
I don't know either.
Oh, shit!
Jump!
Here we go.
We're fine.
Where is my jelly...
Where did he...
Did he die?!
Oh, my God!
When did he die?!
When did my jelly...
Okay.
I don't even know when he died!
He just disappeared!
Jesus Christ, I hate the archers.
I don't know what happened to him!
He just disappeared!
Jesus!
Oh, my God.
I have two flasks left.
Okay.
These are a lot of people.
I might have messed up.
There was a lot of enemies.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Jesus Christ, he just kicks me and I just let him do that?
Alright.
That was a lot of enemies.
Um...
I was not ready for that.
They were pretty tanky.
There's a dog too?!
Seek left then up.
What?
Is there anything to loot?
I thought there was nothing...
I thought I killed it.
Oh, there is.
I didn't even see that.
I don't know why I didn't see that.
Okay, axe.
Okay, nice.
Oh, it means to look up.
Oh, there's an axe.
Seek left then up.
Oh!
There he is!
I see him.
Parkloi.
Park...
It's fine.
Parkour.
We're fine.
Oh my god, we might not be fine.
We might not be fine.
Okay.
I swear to god!
You're such a fucker.
Okay.
I would use my one...
My three arrows just for this.
Okay, nice.
Time for...
Whoa!
I was reading!
I...
What the...
Bro!
Oh, shit.
Reading is...
Reading is dangerous, guys.
I just...
Oh my god.
Who would have thought reading was so dangerous?
Oh my god!
He hit me!
Are you serious?!
Oh my god, you were right here!
You were right here!
Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, I know where he is now.
I swear, oh my god, I swear to fucking God.
There we go.
I s- Are you serious?
We're fine.
Okay, we're okay now.
Might be a little fucked because I don't have a lot of arrows left now.
Okay.
All right, now I have to deal with these guys.
These two.
I don't have my jellyfish.
Don't go up.
Where do I go?
How do I get out of here?
Just run past them?
Oh.
Okay, I got it.
I know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
Never mind.
Okay, watch this, guys.
I'm gonna do not go up.
I do not go up.
There we go.
Hang on.
Oh, my god!
Oh my god!
Where do I go?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Room!
Safe room!
Guys, that room wasn't a safe room.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Who would've thought?
Oh shit!
They're everywhere!
Oh!
When do I stop running?
When can I stop?
Oh!
Wait!
Wrong way!
I have had to go the wrong way!
Oh shit!
Okay!
This way!
Oh my god!
There's so many areas!
Oh!
There's a giant fucking guy!
No!
Please!
Wait!
No!
It's okay!
Don't keep still!
Wrong way!
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay!
Right way!
Here we go!
We got it!
We're safe!
She actually made it!
I was like how do I still go the wrong way!
I have to let go!
I didn't have to let go!
Oh!
Nice!
Thank you for sending support message even though I forgot to submit mine!
Thank you for your streams and bringing smiles!
I'm amazing!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Holy fuck!
Ester thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
What do we upgrade?
I survived guys!
I did it!
With sheer determination!
I survived.
I don't know how I survived that.
I don't know.
It was legs!
Guys, remember I... Guys, remember I boosted the thighs?
Guys!
Gerald, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Plenty, thank you for the super chat.
How the hell gets the legs?
I invested in the thighs!
Chad, I invested in the thighs!
I knew it would be handy someday.
Never skip leg day.
Okay.
Lick thighs, save lives, exactly.
Do we... Do we... Do we nexterity or, like, strength?
Or... Endurance?
Okay.
I'll do, like...
We haven't upgraded strength yet, though.
That's the thing.
Okay.
Nexterity?
Alright, here we go.
Okay, was that an entire dungeon I just ran past?
Jesus Christ, that was a fucking scary dungeon.
Holy fuck.
Weak foe behind.
I survived.
Okay.
I could die here, though.
This could be how I died.
I don't know how I fucked it up, but I did.
I...
Oh my god!
Oh my...
Oh!
No!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
There we go, this time.
I forgot to charge hit it.
That did nothing.
That did nothing!
Oh my god!
How did that do it?
Wait.
Can he make it through?
Oh my god!
That was so scary.
He was running so fast!
Oh.
Yes, he can.
I think he made it through.
That was like a bad dream.
Wait, but can he make it inside this hole?
Wait, I don't think he can!
Wait, I got this!
I figured it out.
Chop!
That's right!
There's no way you can get me from here!
Fight me!
Come on, get in here!
Yeah, that's right!
You don't fit in the hole.
You're too big!
That's right!
You don't fit in the hole!
Oh, you mad!
You're so mad!
That's right!
What you gonna do?
You can't fit in here, you're too big!
That's right!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, I said it!
I said... Bro's mad!
Oh my god, but your minions can!
Your minions can fit in the hole!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, your minions can fit in the hole!
Put me!
No!
I'm sorry!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I didn't think!
That's my sister!
Dad!
Where's my... That's my sister!
It was the karma always, always...
They get it back...
...in the hole...
...thingy...
I can't believe it!
I...
...get it wrecked!
Garlin, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I didn't know he was gonna send him!
I didn't think you was gonna send his...
...his buddies in here!
That's so fucked up!
He sent his friends into the fight!
Wait!
Okay!
I can...
I can kill him!
I believe!
He happened around him!
Fine!
Mark!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay!
Now I know!
His homie said, hold up!
We got this!
What the f- Okay!
Okay!
His friends are scary!
I know he can't get into this hole...
So it's...
Whoa!
Okay!
It's fine!
I have...
Oh my god!
My jellyfish summons doesn't work out here!
My jelly...
Oh my god!
My jellyfish summons don't work here!
My jelly...
Oh my god!
My jellyfish summons don't work here!
Oh no!
Okay!
It's okay!
I believe!
That's right!
Oh!
I did the big mistake!
Oh my god!
I did not think...
I did not think he was there for his buddy!
I didn't think his...
His buddy was just bait!
I...
Oh my god!
I can't believe he used his buddy as bait there!
Okay!
This is fine!
There's no way!
No way!
He'll...
He'll forget about me!
Right?
I killed his friends!
He's gonna forget about me!
Ride and die together!
1v1 time!
Bro!
Turn around!
I'm not here!
How do you know?
I'm behind a wall!
Okay!
I'll crouch!
Now he definitely knows I'm not here!
There's no way he knows!
He's just waiting!
How does he know?
He keeps coming back!
How do you know?
He's just looking at me!
He's just standing there!
Menacingly!
How does he know?
He can smell the fear!
Turn around so I can summon my buddy!
He's fucked up!
He's watching this stream!
Oh thank god he's turning around!
Okay.
Doesn't know.
Jellyfish!
Okay we can do this.
With the power of jellyfish.
We can do this.
Boom!
That's fucking right!
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Shit, jellyfish!
It's okay.
What about the power of jellyfish?
I believe.
Nice!
Okay, I need to recover my stamina.
It's fine.
Jellyfish, please!
One hit!
Die by poison!
That's right, watch this!
My jellyfish will kill... I'm gonna watch my jellyfish 1v1.
You go, jellyfish!
1v1 him!
You got this!
Yay!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
You got beaten by my jellyfish!
It's a poke!
It's almost like Pokemon!
That's right!
I got my Pokemon battle!
Jellyfish, you's toxic!
Nice.
See you guys, it all worked out.
Oh nice, smithing stone.
Jellyfish, I choose you!
Okay.
Does he come back?
Does that...
Oh nice, a golden seed.
Raise the seal.
I'm just curious, does that guy respawn?
Does that guy...
Yes?
Oh shit!
Oh, so he's like a farming thing.
Oh!
Oh, I see.
So he's like a farmer.
Level up before fighting.
Oh wait.
Wait, is that another boss?
Okay.
1k runes?
That's so many runes!
I still don't have enough.
I...
I still don't have enough runes!
That's crazy!
Alright.
You know what?
I'll level up one more time before I do this.
I'll do it one more time.
I'll summon...
I'll summon jellyfish.
Go jellyfish, go.
It's your time to shine.
I...
Why did I turn around?
I don't understand!
How did I turn around?
I don't know!
I don't know to explain!
Someone explain how that happens!
Someone explain!
Someone rewatch the vine and tell me how I turned around!
What are you doing over here?
How did you...
How did you get here?
Oh my god!
He's right here!
I got enough money now?
Alright, let's fuck...
Fuck it.
I don't need to do anything.
Alright.
Okay, what do we get?
Dexterity or strength, guys?
She's just trying her best!
Dexterity?
Okay, dexterity.
More dexterity.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's see how many deaths they'll take us.
One!
Oh wait!
Do I have a...
I think I got a golden seed, too.
I'm pretty sure.
Uh...
Flask.
Did I not get one?
Yeah.
Oh, what?
No!
Oh, I need two!
Two now!
Oh!
Did I get that?
I'm coming for you.
I'm coming for you!
Get over here!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
He's actually 1 HP!
Are you fucking kidding me?
You can't do this to me!
Oh my god!
It's okay!
It was worth it!
Goodbye!
Wait, I didn't even pick it up!
Oh shit!
I didn't even pick it up!
There's no way!
Oh no!
Wait!
There's no way he fits through that.
He's too wide!
There's no way!
There's no way you fit through this!
You're too fucking wide!
That's right!
Time to go on a diet!
Boom!
Oh shit!
Okay, you might be too wide, but you still hit me.
Don't fight, David.
That's right!
Spin all you want, little man!
You can't get me!
Spin all you want!
Boom!
Oh shit!
Okay, I need to heal.
He's a chunky man.
Okay, I don't know how I can miss that.
What the fuck is the range?
Okay.
I still need to figure out the range in this.
Because it always fucks me up for some reason.
I don't know why.
I don't know why this fucks me up.
Doors!
Doors has yet again saved me!
Boom!
Slow and steady!
Good job, door!
Don't pull it!
Blast it!
That's fucking right!
Get doored!
Yeah!
Get fucking doored!
Why is it always Monarch?
Be wary of Liar?
Yeah, I need to get that item.
Let's get rid of one pot first.
And then we'll deal with...
There's so many pots!
Jesus Christ!
Oh wait, was that critical?
Oh shit!
That looked like a critical.
Yeah, that had to be!
Or a Sager?
Okay, they're all dangerous pots.
Oh, that was a guard break.
Okay.
That's right!
I know you're not real!
That's fucking right!
None of you are real!
Get out of here!
Okay, I got crackpot.
And I got another crackpot.
Nice.
I'll end the pot bloodline.
Inspect the strong folk.
Yeah, can't fucking walk through doorways though.
Am I going through here?
Or do I just fight the boss?
Oh, there's somebody over here.
Is there?
Press Q.
Okay, there's you.
There's you guys.
I could just fight the boss.
You know what?
Let's try it.
I believe in us.
Wait, there's something here.
Oh, there's items here.
Oh, nice.
Try jumping?
Why?
Okay, I don't trust them.
Oh, right here!
Okay, I believe.
Okay, then we go this way.
And then...
I...
Oh, wait!
Oh!
Oh, we made it!
Okay.
I don't have to worry about...
Okay, that doesn't do much fall damage.
That's good.
Uh, Kaido!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay, I was worried about the fall damage.
Okay, I have to run jump that.
Okay, now I know.
Okay.
Nice.
Time for jumping and then good luck.
Again?
Why again?
Wait, what?
Why jump again?
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
There's so many people who died there.
Try to make sure there's no enemies.
I'm pressing Q to make sure.
I'm trying to lock into enemies.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, this is like a little place for parkour.
For surprise enemies.
Ooh, items!
Hello!
I like loot.
Okay.
Yay, loot!
Loot!
Loot, loot, loot.
I'm spamming my lock-on button to make sure...
Oh.
I see you.
Oh, I see you guys.
That took me right.
Boom!
Didn't see me, did ya?
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I didn't see you either!
Apparently I didn't see you too!
Okay.
Watch this.
Whoa!
Oh.
Sorry.
I closed my eyes.
What happened?
Guys, what happened?
I closed my eyes.
Did you guys see what happened?
I'm surprised.
Guys, what happened?
Sorry, my eyes were closed.
I don't know.
Be wary of, right?
Wait, where do I go?
Wait, no.
I came down from here.
I came down...
Wait, yeah.
I came...
Where did these guys come from?
I came down from here?
Oh, they came down from here?
Oh, they came down from here.
Alright.
Oh, is it parkour time?
Oh, no.
Is this how all these people died?
Yeah.
Oh, guys.
I don't think we should do it because we have so many so...
Like, we have so many runes.
Let's leave that when we...
Don't worry.
It's not gonna happen to you.
Guys, I don't want to waste all the runes that I got from this area.
I can get it back easy.
Wait, how many runes do I have?
Okay, let me see.
How do I check?
How do I check how many runes I have?
I want to know.
Oh, I have 1,600.
Okay, we don't have a lot.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Do we jump from here or do we go down?
I don't know.
Do we jump from here or do we go downstairs?
Down?
Okay.
Wait, how did this guy die?
Oh.
Where did he go?
How did you die?
He disappeared.
Here.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's so sad.
It's like, yo, that's like, that happened to me too!
It's like, oh my god!
Just like me!
Okay.
Now I'm there for a first stop.
Shortcut.
Wait, what?
I don't trust anyone!
I'm gonna open this door just in case.
Wait, where is this area?
Have I ever been here?
No!
Where the fuck is this area?
Oh, I skipped this when I was running!
Nice.
I've never been here.
I was like, where did I, where did this area come from?
I just, I just ran.
Invisible sword ahead?
What do you mean?
Oh, I can lob up one and pop the rune?
Oh, okay.
I'll do that.
Uh...
Inventory.
Where's my rune?
Oh, this one?
Oh no, that's my golden seed.
Where's the rune?
And that's the golden seed.
The gold circles?
Oh, here it is!
Can I just pop all of these?
Okay, I'll pop all of it.
Boom!
Okay, and then...
Let me pop the rest.
Let's pop all of it.
Yay!
And then...
Oh, I can.
After this last pop.
I should be able to.
Yeah.
Okay, now I should have enough.
Uh...
Alright.
Dexterity.
Do we just keep going with dexterity?
Yeah, I just got enough.
I have more in the next tab?
Really?
Ugh!
Dexterity, the 20.
Okay, I'll do that.
Alright.
Nice.
God, it's so hard to trust people.
This is where trust issues start.
Here we go.
Wait, not there.
Okay.
But it's...
Was this message lying?
Don't...
You mean this message lied to me?
Oh, bad message.
Bad message!
That's it.
I'm mad.
There we go.
Now's my turn.
That...
What is this?
But my...
That continued the cycle.
The...
Two...
Bad messages.
The cycle continues.
He needs another one to reinforce it.
Guys, if y'all get praised that specific message, just think about how many people we'll kill.
It'll be so funny.
Guys, it'd be so funny.
Think about how many people we're gonna kill with that trip.
We all upvoted.
It'd be so funny.
OH SHIT!
Oh my god!
I almost jumped up.
I almost backed up.
What the fuck?
What did he do?
Oh, he fell off.
Okay.
Try target lock?
Oh.
Oh, I see you.
How do I kill him?
How do I kill this guy?
I have a bow.
I have to waste my bow?
God damn it.
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
I could charge attack.
It's too late.
There we go.
You were right.
I could charge attack.
Oh, it's just for that guy?
Be wary of, uh...
That's a long way down.
Oh!
Whoa!
He didn't tell me to be wary of that!
Okay, wait.
I don't think he can fly up.
Yeah, I don't think so either.
Yeah, he's stuck down there.
Yeah, he's a little stupid.
Okay, I can use another bow then.
Stupid.
Here we go.
Get over here.
Head shot.
Come on!
Bro!
Get over here!
Oh my god, he's just sticking out here.
Oh my god, I feel like I'm gonna accidentally fall now.
I...
Okay, now he's just purposely dodging me.
Like, now that's on purpose!
Bro!
Okay, that's fucked up.
I wanna hit him.
I wanna shoot him.
More fun this way.
I'm gonna accidentally back up.
I know, I know I am.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I accidentally used my two arrows!
That's it, I'm mad.
I'm mad now.
I'm mad!
Get over here.
There we go.
I could've just done that.
Yeah, but my other arrows are strong arrows.
That's different.
Where did he die?
What?
What the f- What?
How many are you- Are there?
Wait, I can do this one.
Wait, is this worth it?
Is this- Is this worth it?
Wait.
No, don't do what that guy did.
Is it- Is it worth it though?
Is it actually- Is it- How badly you wanna find out- I- I don't- I don't- I don't know if- I don't know if- I don't know if it's worth it.
It doesn't seem worth it.
No, there's another way down!
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
Okay, we got that.
Alright.
Okay.
Why is it always a rat- No!
No, not the rats!
Not the fucking rats!
Are you fucking- Is this rat territory?
Ah, I see them!
I see the rats!
I see them!
Are they poisonous?
Is this poison- Ah, I'm using the bathroom.
Fuck this.
Be right-
I'll be right back.
Sorry, I had to go- I forgot to get water.
I got my water though.
Oh my god.
Are we appraising that one message where I told people to jump?
Good.
We continue the cycle.
Upvote it, please.
I want to see how many people will jump.
I can't-
Wait, I'm just gonna- Fuck it.
I'm gonna waste my arrows.
Can't be bothered.
Wait, what?
How do I swap my arrows?
You have arrows!
How do I swap it?
Autodock?
Yeah, but it's not swapping my arrows.
I don't know how to swap my ammo.
Oh!
There we go.
Whoops.
Do you think they know this?
Who's that, Jerry?
I don't know.
He's like, who's that?
What was?
Do you think they know?
I don't know, I'm tired.
Let's just go back to being rats.
Rats.
We are the rats.
First up, is something incredible then be wary of...
What?
How did they all die?
How did they...
Wait.
How did they all die?
Was it the rats?
Oh, no.
I think it was the rats, guys.
Oh my god.
I think it's the rats.
I'm so worried.
How did they all die?
There's so many rats ahead.
Oh!
That was a rat!
It was the rat!
Holy shit!
That's a big-ass rat!
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I know now.
Yep.
I was like, how did they die to a rat?
LOL.
That's out.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We figured it out.
It was...
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
It was a giant rat.
You're like, something shining.
Rat down.
Welcome to New York City.
Yeah, but like, 800 people died.
You're up ahead?
I was confused how so many people died in this one area.
I'm so paranoid.
Run!
No running!
Okay.
Nice.
I'm so paranoid.
I'm spamming Q, guys.
I'm spamming Q.
I gotta be sure.
God.
What's this?
There's so many bodies here.
There's so many.
There's so many bodies.
Oh no.
That's a graveyard.
That's a...
Where's my golden trail?
This is a bot...
There's no way.
What?
But look at the loot though.
Look at the loot.
Where's the...
How do...
There's no save point!
How is this a boss point with no save point?
Oh.
Oh, I see that guy rolling.
I see him roll.
He's doing the same thing I am.
He's going through the same thing I'm going through right now.
Okay.
Guess I go down.
Oh my god.
Jellyfish.
Oh my god!
How is he easy?
He's so big!
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
Where's my jellyfish?
What?
Ah!
Freeze me!
Stop!
What the... I forgot where the messages were.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for the appraisals.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Thanks for the appraisals, everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
They really helped out.
For sure.
They really did.
I feel very helped out.
Oh, my God.
Thanks for playing Elden Ring with us.
Skarden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where the fuck were my appraisals?
I was lied to.
Oh, yeah.
I can't believe it.
I don't know how I keep missing those shots.
There you go.
I'm so sad.
Oh, my God.
Alright, there's a giant rat.
Rat.
Get out of here.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
It hit me?
Okay.
That's fine.
Why did no... Why did none of these messages say anything about this giant fucking thing up there?
Get ratted.
I'm tired of getting ratted.
Wait, there was a parkour area right here.
I'm headed to nowhere.
Be wary of high spot?
Why?
What's this even for?
Why is it always...
...mess?
Let's go!
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but like, what is this fucking high ground even for?
It's for nothing.
Therefore, do it.
Whoa.
Can I just run through it?
Maybe I can just run through it.
Maybe I can just... Oh, fuck!
Maybe he can't go through this.
Maybe I can just run through this.
Maybe...
Maybe I can just...
Guys, stop appraising!
I'm okay!
Wait.
But where do I go afterwards?
Does he know I'm here?
Oh my god, there's a ladder right there.
I don't think he can see me.
I don't think...
This is it.
No!
Climb!
Climb, you fool!
Keep climbing, you fool!
Keep climbing!
Climb!
Pass it!
Climb for your life!
We'll come back later.
What a thrill!
What a...
Oh my god, it's so high up!
Why is it so high up?
We're so...
It's like a dream!
Snake eater!
What's down here?
Wait, I can't go back down from here.
Wait, what's down here?
Guys, what the fuck is down here?
I... By
the way, be wary of enemy?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
This has to be a... Okay, I can't go through here.
Okay.
Wait, open the guard.
Oh.
Okay.
There's no way he can get through this door.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, he can.
There you go.
I got it.
I don't know.
He seemed really fucking big for some reason.
I don't think he knows I'm here.
I don't think he saw me.
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
I knew he didn't see me.
I knew it.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
That's so many things.
Liar ahead?
Oh.
There you go.
Time for jumping off.
Oh, it's... I would... That's what he meant.
Liar ahead.
Wait, I should... Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea, too.
Try... Wait, I want to be like, he's right.
Is there like...
Um... No liar ahead.
No...
No liar ahead.
There you go.
There was... Guys... No, there wasn't a liar.
It said so.
He's right.
Upvote.
I upvote with my own message.
Which one is telling the truth.
Spreading misinformation.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Was that... That...
There's literally just going down the...
Jump into... Back into the pit of doom.
Like, there he is.
I see him right there.
Is there anything else right here?
All right.
Koala, thank you for the super chat.
I love doing these messages.
Scarlet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not gonna lie.
These messages are really fun.
Community noted.
Who's gonna community note me?
In fact, you guys should like, appraisal it.
Wait, can you go through this door?
There's no way.
He's so thick.
There's no way he can.
All right.
I already community noted you.
That's right.
Too thick.
You can't do nothing.
That's right.
You're too thick.
Just like those pots.
Oh my god.
He has so much range though.
Jesus Christ.
Don't get that range on this guy.
That's cheating.
Me using the door isn't cheating, guys.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
I can't even...
Okay.
I know what to do.
Okay, I don't want to waste all of my arrows.
Guys, I'm not wasting all of my arrows.
But like, I'm still trying to figure out how to like...
deal with this guy.
Oh my god.
What's wrong?
Why are you so mad?
Why are you mad?
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Why are you so mad?
He's trying.
I'll piss you off.
Yeah, I'm trying to.
But he's...
He's just so...
He's just standing there.
Wait, there's something above.
Dude.
Who the fuck is above?
What is this?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Don't watch.
Alright, it's time.
Wait, I can't crack?
Oh my god.
I didn't...
Where's the elevator?
Later.
I'm letting you try.
Oh, thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm gonna... I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do the yellow.
You're right.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
I learned my lesson.
Phew!
There we go.
Alright.
Yeah, no.
Fuck that guy.
No, after I saw the range, fuck that guy.
Okay.
He made me closer to the door.
God, closer!
Be in this one door!
Apparently he deserves cheese, apparently, from what you guys tell me.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
Get over here.
Come on.
Come on, come on.
Come on, get over here.
Come on!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know you want to...
I think he knows I wanna cheese him.
Oh my god, I think he knows.
Jesus Christ.
This range is actually crazy.
Like, what the fuck?
What the fuck?!
Are you serious?!
I can't even get close to him!
He's actually...
What the fuck?!
Oh my god.
He's actually bullshit.
Behind us!
Oh my god!
Look where he's trying to hit me!
I...
Okay.
He's just...
Moving along.
Alright.
What?
I'm the one step!
I'm the...
When I'm throwing knives, you're so right.
Give me a sec, let me...
Let me put that in.
Let me just...
Let me just do that.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Okay.
Does two damage.
Okay, wait, I can...
Can I still not craft?
He's not even looking at me!
You're right, I'll put in a shortcut.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of...
We're gonna...
Switch this real quick.
Alright.
Okay, I need him to do this.
We have to cheese him.
He's like, blocking my only way.
And he's... he's a pain.
Right now, he's actually an asshole.
I...
I'm so dumb.
I can't...
I...
I just... I don't know.
I just think he'd block it, you know?
I don't know why.
I thought he wasn't gonna block it.
Here we go.
I don't know.
I thought he was just gonna let me do my thing.
Here we go.
One more.
I...
One last hit.
Oh, my God!
He doesn't care!
He just...
He so...
He's so loud...
Oh my god.
How is he allowed to just do that?
That was bullshit.
He fucking... He actually just moved to the right.
Oh my god.
That's so bullshit.
I can't believe he just, like, walked, like, to the right and then, like, fucked me up.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm moving to the right.
I can't believe it.
Wait, I can craft arrows now.
Let me craft that in the middle of the area.
Alright.
Is it this one?
Bone dart?
I can only craft bone dart.
Wait, I don't even have arrows.
The giant tree spirit gives golden sea and rewards you for taking down strong opponents.
Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
I don't have the cookbook for arrows.
I just have darts.
I'll just make darts for now.
Fuck it.
Where's the grace?
Oh, there's a dog here.
How bad can a dog be?
Oh, there's two dogs.
Oh.
Really bad?
Okay.
I hate to have to go this way.
I guess.
Oh, that's good to know.
Oh, there's a grace.
There it is.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
For some reason.
Oh, thank god.
Grace consumed.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I don't know where I am.
Alright, I can level up.
I guess more dexterity.
I feel so safe.
Safety.
Oh, where do I go?
I'm so fucking lost.
Where am I?
I'm exploring this dungeon in reverse right now.
Oh yeah, because I skipped everything here.
I'm like, I don't know where I am anymore.
I'm so confused.
Oh, there's a bird.
Is it a nice bird?
Hello.
Wait, is that a barrel?
Oh yeah, this is where I ran through everything.
I remember this area.
I ran through all of that.
I don't think it's a nice bird.
That seems like a barrel that goes kaboom.
You know what?
Let's try the boss fight.
I believe.
All right.
Wait, not here.
I don't have any arrows.
Was it here?
Wait.
Oh, I should upgrade my weapon.
You're right.
Let me teleport.
I forgot about my weapons.
Okay.
He's like, right.
He's like, right here.
Hello.
I need weapons.
Well, where have you been hiding?
I took you for dead.
No matter.
It's all the same.
Lay out your arms then.
All right.
Strength then.
How much money do I have?
Wait, do I not have money?
Oh, no.
I don't.
Oh, it's because I upgraded.
Don't worry.
I still have some...
Orbs.
Oh, that's my golden seed.
Where was it?
No, I picked up one.
Oh, there it is.
That should be enough.
Boom.
Back already.
All right.
No matter.
Lay out your arms.
I think I have enough, right?
Yeah, I do.
Wait, I don't have...
Wait, what do I need?
What am I missing?
Oh, I need one more smithing stone.
Ah.
I need more smithing stone.
Yeah.
Can you buy smithing stone or no?
Buy at the old hag?
Who the fuck is the old hag?
It's cheap?
Is it a church?
Oh, later in the game.
Oh, it's the hag that's old, Doki.
God.
All right.
Let's try this boss fight.
I'm getting a little tired, though.
So, we'll see how I feel after I try that boss fight.
We'll see.
Does the church might have one?
Oh, does the church have one?
Oh, the merchant here has one?
Okay, let me see.
Let's see if the merchant has one.
All right.
Talk to me.
Okay.
I don't think he has one.
What about the church merchant?
Does the church merchant have one or no?
What the fuck is kill?
Oh, I need an item for him to sell it?
What the fuck is...
Is that Santa?
Oh, I should get the recipe for arrows.
You're right.
I should.
It's like...
Here.
Okay.
That's Santa.
All right.
All right, Santa.
I need my stones.
Weren't you...
Well, you're back.
I'm back.
Care to buy something?
Yeah, I survived.
Okay, purchase.
Does he have a...
Okay, arrow.
Cookbook.
Which one is he?
No, he has throwing daggers.
Is this one or...
Cookbook one or cookbook two?
Wait, is it cookbook one or cookbook two?
That has arrows.
I don't want to waste my...
Oh, press R.
Oh, I can see it?
Oh!
Bone arrow.
Okay, it's this one.
All right, nice.
I didn't want to waste it.
Goodbye.
Nice to do business.
All right.
I guess we'll...
Go to the boss now.
Wait, not here.
I keep thinking of...
This is the fast travel.
When I can just press my map.
It's secluded sale.
All right.
Let's see how fucked up it's gonna be.
Let's see.
All right.
This could be my eighth death.
So we'll see from here.
This could be my...
Eighth death right here.
All right.
Here I'll go.
Mighty dragon.
Thirted true born heir.
Lemme thy strength, oh kindred.
Deliver me unto...
Can the influencer build survive this?
I did not create a lot of messages.
So let's see.
I forgot to equip the jelly.
Pause.
Tree Sentinel.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, I forgot.
Pause.
Please.
Parley.
Hey!
Time out!
We each get one time out!
Oh my god, wait.
You gave me a time out.
Wait, it worked!
It worked!
Time out over!
Guys, I got the time out!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, thanks for the time out.
Thanks for the time out.
Holy shit!
Holy fuck!
He's almost dead!
Oh
my god!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ!
Guys, how is he easier?
How is he easier?
Oh my god!
I was lied too!
It was absolutely not easier!
He won!
Oh my god!
I ran into the wind!
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
He actually is easy.
He's easier, but you skipped the entire level.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
I just need to figure out his pattern.
I need to figure out his pattern.
It'll be fine.
We just... We just need to figure out his pattern.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure it out.
My poor jellyfish.
Oh my god!
I can't run!
Oh my god.
My poor jellyfish.
My poor guy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Are you... How does...
How does...
How does he predict that...
Oh my god.
He punishes right-handed people.
Am I underleveled?
Am I...
Guys.
Keep it to me straight.
Am I underleveled right now?
Am I...
Probably.
I need to know.
Am I...
Am I underleveled?
Oh, I'm not.
Okay.
Okay, I'm not.
A little maybe.
Just a little.
Okay.
It's just a little.
That's fine.
Jeez.
Oh my god.
They're lying, dude.
You are indeed.
Okay.
After this, maybe I'll level up a little bit.
Of course.
Okay.
I know my summons is a little underleveled though.
Oh my god.
My jellyfish.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I should have achieved that.
No!
Might have been a mistake.
Might have been a mistake right there.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, I don't trust that.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
What is he doing?
Why did he cut his arm off?
Why did he cut his arms off?
What the fuck?
He can just...
Do that?
Oh my god, he's alive!
Oh shit.
Goodbye, my buddy.
Goodbye.
Guys, I think my jellyfish might be dead.
Oh my god.
He crashed me!
No!
Let me go!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, freeze!
Appraise me!
Thank you!
Thank you for the appraise!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh shit!
Good appraise!
Oh my god!
Oh!
That would have been so clutch.
Oh, that was crazy.
Okay, we gotta farm a little bit.
We have to farm a little bit.
That was not good for us.
Almost carried by a phrase.
Oh, my God.
I just gotta get through.
I'm just gonna level up one to two more times.
My build is so OP.
Oh, shit.
I gotta run.
Gotta get the little guy out of the way.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
And it's free.
Okay.
Okay, we can kill him now.
Oh, my God.
That's not bad.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I need to actually... I need to get out of here.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Stupid dragon arm though.
Dragon arm is fucking crazy.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, yep.
Jeez!
Oh!
He slapped me!
Holy fuck!
Okay, I did not expect him to slam me like that.
Okay, that was awkward.
Oops... I did not expect to squash... Alright, this time... I did not dodge.
No, I admit... I might have fucked up, because I didn't dodge.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Kill those guys.
Do that again.
Ooh, that again.
Ooh, nice.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, get me out of here!
Get me out of here!
Okay, nice.
Bye.
Believe in the power of poison.
Jesus.
Okay.
This should be good now.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Whoa, that was scary.
Alright, let's explore.
Okay, we're gonna heal here, and then we'll go back to exploring.
We'll go back to going through this dungeon.
Ah, I keep fucking it up.
Okay, it's here.
The rampart tower.
Yeah, maybe we'll find some smithing stones.
I don't know.
I guess I'll go this way.
Why?
Have I, like, in here?
Okay, no, I have not.
I've skipped everything here.
This is the elevator I came from.
I pull this lever?
Wait, contraption does not move?
Why?
Why no move?
Shit.
Alright.
Got this.
Let's just walk through here.
Alright.
Let's go through here.
Yeah, try to... I was actually trying to jump.
No!
Hurry up.
Where the fuck is the arrow guy?
How do I get to you?
Come and roll, bitch.
Wait.
Never mind.
I guess... I guess I'm not coming over.
Okay.
Can I jump on that?
I wonder.
Jump on the wheel.
This wheel?
Let's see.
Let's see if I can.
Oh, my god.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Ho, ho, ho, ho.
That's right.
Turn French a little there.
Uh... Ho, ho, ho.
My core.
Alright.
Where am I?
This is the story.
Where I'll never know where I am.
Oh, there you are.
Dan.
Oh, not you.
No.
Oh, you're so far.
You're so far.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
What?
Nice.
I'm fine.
I might have missed.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
I hate these win attacks.
These win attacks are so dumb.
These win attacks are so fucking dumb.
Jesus Christ.
That's fine.
Oh, I got smithing stone.
Yippee!
Got what I needed.
Okay.
I got golden.
Is that it?
Okay.
That's it, right?
Sniper ahead?
Where?
I gotta jump to the pillars?
What pillars?
Oh, these?
Now, where do I go?
You want me to go?
That's that one?
That area right there?
There's an area right there.
Okay.
Oh, here.
Oh, my god.
Accidentally, I'm almost fucking that up.
Wait, I'm back here.
Shit went that way.
I'm back here.
Other tower.
Wait, where's the other tower?
This one?
Okay.
I know how to get there.
It's, like, here.
Do I fight the friendly birds?
Do they seem- You know what?
They seem friendly.
Let's just heal up, then.
Alright.
Wait, how much do I have?
Oh, I almost have Lola.
Alright, let's do it.
They seem so friendly.
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
See, I told you.
They seem so friendly.
Oh, my God, they twirl so much.
Okay, nice.
Jesus, they twirl so much.
I got confused.
How do they not get, like, damage?
Like, friendly fire by that.
That should be friendly fire.
First off, jumping.
How did he die?
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's how he died.
Okay.
I don't think he made it.
I don't think he...
Okay, I just want to be sure.
I just...
Okay, guys.
This might go horribly wrong.
I mean...
This could go horribly wrong.
Oh, I need that.
Okay.
Seek home.
Seek down.
Wait, how did he fuck that up?
You just go forward.
How did that happen?
Try skill.
Oh, nice.
How did he fuck that up?
How did he just go...
He just go straight.
Okay.
I'm so paranoid.
Liar ahead.
Oh, shit.
Which one?
There's so many of us.
Down ahead.
Wait, is this the liar?
I don't know.
Who's lying?
Okay.
Who's the liar?
Vision of hope.
Vision of house.
Oh, this one?
Can't trust nobody.
Not even myself.
Vision of God.
Wait.
No.
Okay.
Wait.
There's...
There's a rock here.
What now?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my God.
There was hope.
I feel like I'm gonna accidentally like kill myself right here.
Oh my God.
I just have to believe.
I have to believe.
Holy fuck.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Just gotta believe.
That guy's gonna push me off.
Oh no.
It's him.
What do you mean?
Oh no.
I'm crafting arrows.
I don't have bones.
I forgot to farm.
I used all my bones for the stupid things.
I...
Run past him.
Okay.
I know what to do.
Never mind.
My horse doesn't wanna play today.
Wait.
Does he see me?
Follow my heart.
I feel so safe.
I feel so safe right now.
There he is.
Right there.
Just chillin'.
Yeah.
But how important is that?
Don't skip.
You gotta teach him a lesson.
I'll let future Doki handle that.
Future Doki can teach him a lesson.
Current Doki is trying to figure out where I am.
Wait.
I love you.
Shortcut.
Let it speak.
Behold.
Seems something.
Oh.
That's like where I started.
Yeah.
I assume that's the shortcut.
Okay.
Nice.
Up.
Try luring out.
Snake.
Snake?
Where's Snake?
Snake where?
I'm scared.
What does he mean by Snake?
Oh.
This area.
I'm back here.
Yay.
Alright.
Now.
Now I save and then we kill that guy.
Does he give a lot of...
Does he give a lot?
Wait.
Do we have enough?
No.
We still don't have...
Wait.
I must have items, right?
Let me check.
Oh.
I have...
How much is that?
400?
I have...
No.
I don't have enough.
Okay.
I believe.
Actually, let's kill these guys and get level up first.
I want to get level up before we go in.
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
He spanded on me.
He may or may not be better.
Oh, I'm going to come back for you.
I'm going to come back.
I know how to do this jump.
I know how I'm coming back to... Okay.
Okay... Let me lock in first.
Let me... There we go.
There we go.
I had... There was an issue.
I forgot to press Q.
Okay, I'm okay now, though.
Oh, I should be... No, I need like two more.
There was a slight issue, but I'm okay now.
All right.
Wait.
This way, right?
Where's the other... The entrance for that fucking... For those enemies.
Oh.
God, he scared me.
I was not ready.
I was actually not ready.
I can take them.
Okay, we're gonna... We're... Wait.
Do I have enough?
Three... Oh, we should.
Right, right?
It's 3,600, right?
Fight the birds.
Oh, you're right.
I can fight the birds.
The birds... Don't the birds insta-kill me, though?
If they hit the barrel correctly?
That's what I'm worried about.
Oh, sorry.
Wrong way.
Back down I go...
To hell...
Go back up.
Nah, you take those.
Just don't get hit.
It's just that easy.
Where the fuck... Oh, it's the birds are over here.
All right.
Hello.
Hello, not friendly birds.
Jesus.
Where's...
Okay.
That should be fine.
98.
All right.
Get over here.
My non-friendly birds.
Nice.
What the fuck?!
Ah, shit!
Okay, that was a little cheating.
Are you see- Oh!
No way!
Oh my god, there's no way.
Oh my god, buy one HP.
Oh my god.
I'm...
Goodbye.
Thanks for the appraisal.
Good timing.
Let me...
Okay.
Let me grab...
Let me use this.
Clutch.
Damn.
Clutch appraisal right there.
All right.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
You guys help me decide what to love next.
All right.
Butter.
Metis.
Slake.
Bite size.
Niarr.
Uh...
Syrah.
Matt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Guys.
What do we do?
Need more?
Okay.
We need more...
HP.
All right.
And then...
I forgot what my plan was after that.
What was our plan?
Oh yeah.
We fight that guy.
I can take him now.
I have more HP.
I believe.
Oh yeah.
We don't need...
We upgrade our weapon later.
He's like over here.
I believe.
I don't have nothing to lose too.
I have nothing to lose!
Do I survive this?
Where is he?
Wait.
Oh!
Welcome to tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Of course I wash my hands.
Where did he go?
Wait.
Where is he?
Who's this fucker?
What?
Free item.
Oh my god.
It didn't even matter.
Oh, there he is.
All right.
I hide here.
There's no way he sees me.
There's no way.
Wait, guys.
He's a little like...
Guys, he's a lot bigger than I thought.
Wait.
Guys.
Wait a minute.
Wait, I did not realize how big he was.
I...
You know what?
You're right.
I can take him.
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
He doesn't...
Oh my god.
He knows.
He knows I'm in the bushes now.
Guys.
Guys!
Goodbye.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I have a plan.
I have an idea.
Oh, shit.
What's he gonna do?
Jump down?
Oh my god!
Okay, my plan is I do this.
Okay, I thought I... I thought... Clearly, I was wrong.
My plan was to see if I could push him off.
But it clearly didn't work.
Okay.
Wait, I have an idea.
He'll jump down, right?
He's gonna jump down?
Yeah?
And then... Oh my god!
You're right!
Watch this!
That's right.
Come over here.
Come on!
Where did he go?
I don't know.
Oh!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
I can push him off.
He doesn't stagger.
He... He... Oh no.
Oh no.
I have a plan.
He's gonna follow me.
Watch this.
Wait.
It goes up.
Oh, I thought that goes down.
I... Whoops.
That goes up.
I forgot this goes up.
I... I thought, like, you know, I go up the elevator and he's just gonna fall through the hole.
He... When he's supposed to... That was the plan.
Okay, wait, I can do this.
We can do this again.
I believe.
There's no way.
I almost got...
Wait, there's a hole!
Wait, it almost worked!
It almost worked!
Wait, wait, there's a hole!
Wait!
Wait, we can make this work!
Wait, I'm a fucking genius!
If there's a hole, there's a goal.
Where did he go?
This is doable.
This is so... Imagine the... The runes I can get, though.
Where is he?
I don't like that.
I don't know where he is.
Wait, did he actually fall through and live?
Wait,
did he actually fall through and live?
Wait, he's just right there!
He's just...
Did
he do it?
Yes!
I did it!
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Yes!
I do it!
And there's a hole!
There's a goal!
Wait, look, he did it!
No way!
He did it!
I'm so fucking smart!
I didn't work!
You learned nothing!
I learned that if there's a hole, there's always a goal!
It's...
I learned!
That's my...
Oh, gee!
Wait, we might be able to get loot!
Let's go back down!
Look, he did it.
I got a hat.
I got a hat, though.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait.
I think... I got a hat, guys.
It's a pretty cool hat.
Oh, I don't think I can get the item.
I think his body is gone.
God.
Oh, I got it.
Nice.
That loot was a skill.
Sweet.
Nice.
Let's go.
Zero deaths from that one guy.
Let's fucking go.
Look.
See?
I told you.
I told you there was a way.
Alright.
Let's try and grab one more loot.
Oh, yeah.
We should...
Fuck.
I keep doing this.
I keep thinking this is the faster I will...
Some say he's still falling to this day.
Okay.
Let's see.
Uh... It's right here.
I should be able to upgrade my weapon now.
I knew it.
Work smarter, not harder.
Guys.
I'm...
Alright.
Strengthen.
Uh...
Yes.
Strengthen this right...
Right now.
Yeah, this is my first time playing it.
You can tell how cheesy I am.
Hehehehehehehe.
Hehehehehe.
Alright.
Let's see.
Hey Bandai!
Thanks for hanging out with us today!
I really appreciate it.
Alright.
Let's farm the big guy.
We need like 2k points so we can do...
We'll do one more level up and then see how I feel against...
Against him!
Only one more level up.
Alright.
This is the easiest to farm anyway.
Jellyfish.
Jellyfish!
Go!
Do your thing, my jellyfish.
Boom!
Okay, we leave now.
We leave.
We leave now.
Maybe he'll crush his team.
Mace.
That's like my plan.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I'll fight a little, guys.
You do your thing!
Alright, he killed his own friends.
That's good.
Okay.
There you go.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit!
Why am I on my bow?
My bow!
Oh!
Wrong move!
More move!
Wrong move.
I don't know why I had my bow out.
That's awkward.
Wait.
Let me steal your stuff here.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
This input right there.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
I did not realize that I had... Oh, fuck!
I wasn't trying to press... There you go.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Yummy.
Oh shit.
Oh, yeah, I got the seeds.
Don't worry.
That was the first thing I did.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay, let me heal right here.
Now, let's do double heal.
Where?
What if?
What if where?
Okay.
Fine.
That's fine.
Nice.
Oh my god, I can't get near the head.
It's too far.
The head is too far.
Pass the trail?
Wait, the wife is there?
I never saw the wife.
I never saw the maiden.
Where wife?
Wife important.
Yeah?
Is that woman?
Woman!
Be proud.
If only I had a knight!
And this time is the first master.
And the only ones left to you.
To a higher place.
Nice.
God, oh God, wait, wait, wait.
Who do we have here?
Tarnished, are you?
Clearly not one of Godric's lot.
I am Nefeli Lu.
Tarnished and warrior like you.
I'm here by decree of my brother.
He needs you, man.
Oh, no.
Oh, is this the NPC?
Is this the NPC?
I'm certain father would permit me aid the fight.
Apologies.
But I've idled long enough.
I swear at times we must each follow our own guidance.
Down whatever road takes us to the throne of Elden Lord.
Oh, okay.
All right, message time.
Every time I see a maiden.
Let's see.
Uh...
Where is it?
Where is he?
Joy.
Ah, joy.
Nice.
There we go.
Finally.
Maiden.
How do you summon her?
That's not right.
Alright.
Last level up.
The golden side.
She makes the fight trivial?
What does that mean?
Oh!
Before a door.
Okay.
Health?
We'll go with health.
Alright.
We're bringing the maiden along because she's woman.
Come with me, woman.
She does all the work?
She does most of the... Oh, it makes it super easy?
Oh!
If I get talisman out of it?
Oh, I like free stuff.
Alright.
I'm touching it.
I'm touching the side.
I like free stuff.
Hello.
Free stuff time.
Oh, hey, Tenjin.
Come over here.
Oh, she has double axes too.
I believe.
Alright.
It's been a while.
Wait, where is she?
I was gonna be like, where did she go?
Hey, why is he looking at me?
Hey.
E- E- E- E- E- A- E- Agrox Jesus cri- what- what the- What the fuck?
A- A- What the fuck what the fuck?
The wind attack really?
R U S Oh my god.
I forgot about how to fight him.
It's been so long, guys.
I actually forgot how to fight this guy.
It's been way too long.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god, Jesus.
I forgot how to fight him.
Like, his win attack is actually crazy, though.
Okay.
I'm backing up.
Oh, he's using the dragon.
How do I skip?
Oh, skip.
I don't need to see that again.
Because I might die.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's okay.
Again?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
He's using it on him.
No, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Dodge!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
That's not fine.
Dodge, dodge, dodge.
Oh my god.
You do so much.
Thank you.
I told you I'm not maiden-less.
I...
Look at her go.
I knew it.
Thank you, wife.
Thank you.
See, I didn't let her die.
She's okay.
I didn't let her die.
Look at that.
I'm a good person.
I defeated have lost her beneficial power.
However, their power can be restored at Divine Towers.
Discover which Divine Tower you should visit.
What?
What does that mean?
Look at that.
I told you.
Ah, joy.
I...
Josh, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Easy clap.
Let's go.
I told you.
Ah, joy.
Oh, that long, long court.
Oh, the one with the lion?
The witch and the wardrobe?
Oh, hey.
Hey there, buddy.
Nice seeing you here.
All right, what's next?
Let's see.
Chilling with the ghost.
Is it more health time?
I could do a lot of health.
Until 30?
Jesus Christ.
What about, like, my attacks, guys?
Get it to 30.
All right.
All right, I'm almost at 30 anyway.
Hey, buddy.
Let's see.
Is there anything here?
No?
Okay.
We have...
So what is the...
The towers is the...
The lion, right?
Where the lions are?
Right?
Yeah?
All right.
I'm gonna head to...
I'm gonna head here.
All right, we're gonna call it here.
Yes, but talk...
But till this...
Talk to this...
Which dude?
Which guy am I supposed to talk to?
I mean, I killed two bosses, you know?
I think that's good enough.
Wait, is that my message?
Yeah, that's my message.
A high flick sinky with...
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, he was at the boss room?
Oh yeah.
Is my message still here?
Wait, how many praises do you get?
Jenner...
If only I had a lover.
Nice...
Okay.
Oh, right here?
At Godric?
There's a guy here.
Nice.
All right, let's talk to him.
Where is he?
There's a guy here?
Where the fuck is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
I thought he was... Time for joy!
Oh.
Hello.
Oh my god, wait, that's Godric.
Oh.
He has issues.
Yeah, this guy has issues.
Hello there.
This weasel was... Godric was always looking down on me.
He got what he bloody deserve thanks to you.
I'll tell you though.
Yeah, all me.
All us.
Me and my dragoons.
He had an ugly heart.
An ugly countenance.
And met the ugliest of ends, eh?
Me and my wife, you're right.
Oh, I can buy stuff?
What have you got theFT.
Sievel pickled fowl foot.oder.
temple boost item discovery.
Proalog.
It reveals co -op.
I mean, it doesn't feel like there's anything for it.
Yeah, it doesn't feel like arrows?
We don't need that.
Okay.
Is that it?
Wait, the armor?
Is the armor good?
Armor and weapons.
I mean, he doesn't have any weapons.
He just has...
I feel like... Do I... Should I get the armor?
Nah?
Alright.
Oh, it's the band that's starting.
Okay.
Alright, goodbye.
Alright, we're gonna call it here.
Oh my... Oh my god, we've been going for five hours.
Holy shit.
I mean, five hours, two bosses?
That's good progress right there.
Whoops.
Oh, I don't wanna get that out of here.
Oh!
That was fun!
That was really fun, guys.
Wait, how do I save?
System...
Is it automatically save for me?
I hope it's saved!
Oh, just exit the game?
But yeah!
Thank you, everybody, for coming!
I had a great time playing Eldering for the first time.
To be fair, I'm cheesing a lot.
I...
I hope you guys are enjoying my playthrough, despite all the cheesing I'm doing!
I hope you guys have fun watching.
I do play it quite uniquely.
There's nothing wrong with cheese.
My rat...
Look!
I have...
I do play Souls games.
Very...
Very special.
If you watch my Bloodborne playthrough, it was very similar to how I played Bloodborne.
Because I love the cheese.
I play it in a very particular way.
Dork, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm ready for another Simpsons save moment.
But it's definitely been really fun.
Look, guys.
I could have spent an hour trying to kill the big, big bulky guard guy.
But instead, I just made him fall.
And saved myself...
40 minutes.
50 minutes of trying to kill him.
That's all I'm saying.
So true.
Problem solved.
Anyway.
That was really fun.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was a lot of fun and so fun.
You're so adorable.
Never change your cheese away.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad everybody had a fun time.
I always love streaming for you guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you all for watching.
Tomorrow...
I don't even remember what I'm streaming tomorrow.
Is it Simpsons or Dynasty Warriors?
I don't remember.
Um...
I'm like...
I lost track of my schedule.
I...
Is it Dynasty Warriors?
Guys, I spent like an hour and a half leveling up in Dynasty Warriors.
Because I was like...
I am not...
I'm not...
And then I had to Google...
I was like Googling like...
What...
What builds do I need to do?
Because I'm not gonna...
We're not having another part 11 or part 12 in Dynasty Warriors.
We are finishing that game tomorrow.
Uh...
Check.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Dough Kitty isn't real.
She can't hurt me.
Dough Kitty pushes him down a hole.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey guys.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna call it here.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
Before I go.
My show of the day.
Um...
I still have my hi...
Hiatt PC stuff.
So if you guys ever...
You know...
Want a custom PC case.
A custom DokiBird PC case.
Or like...
A desk Mac.
Or all that.
It's still around.
So yeah.
Um...
Please check that out.
Please check it out.
And bye, bye, bye, bye.
Hahaha.
So that's my show of the day.
Anyway guys.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.